- Welcome to the Huberman Lab Podcast,
where we discuss science
and science based tools
for everyday life.
[upbeat rock music]
I'm Andrew Huberman,
and I'm a professor of
neurobiology and ophthalmology
at Stanford School of Medicine.
Today, my guest is Dr. Paul Conti.
Dr. Conti is a psychiatrist
who did his training at
Stanford School of Medicine,
and then went on to be chief resident
at Harvard Medical School.
He now runs the Pacific Premier Group,
which is a collection of
psychiatrists and therapists
focusing on solving
complex human problems,
including trauma, addiction, personality,
and psychiatric disorders.
Today, we discuss trauma in detail
and the therapeutic process in detail.
For instance, we discuss what is trauma?
How do you know if you have trauma?
Dr. Conti shares with us, for instance,
that not every experience
that we think is traumatic
is necessarily traumatic
and yet many people might have trauma
without even realizing it.
We also talk about the
therapeutic process generally,
for instance, how to pick a therapist,
how to best approach
and go through therapy
and how to evaluate whether or not therapy
and your relationship to the
therapist is working or not.
We also talk about self
therapies because we acknowledge
that not everyone has access
to or can afford therapy.
And we talk about drug therapies,
for instance, antidepressants,
antipsychotics.
We talk about alcohol, cannabis,
ketamine and the psychedelics,
including psilocybin, LSD.
And we talk about the clinical use of MDMA
and what the future of that looks like.
The reason for bringing
Dr. Conti onto this podcast
is because I see him as the person
who has the greatest and most
holistic view of therapy,
trauma, drug therapies, talk therapies,
and how self therapy and work
with others can be integrated
for both healing and growing
from difficult circumstances.
Dr. Conti is also the author
of an exceptional book,
entitled "Trauma: The Invisible Epidemic,
How trauma works and how
we can heal from it."
That book describes trauma
and its many features and many tools,
some of which we discuss
on the podcast today.
So whether or not you have trauma or not,
by the end of today's episode,
you will have a much deeper understanding
about what trauma is.
In fact, I'm confident
that you will gain insight
into whether or not
you have trauma or not,
whether or not people close
to you have trauma or not
and the various paths to
recovering and indeed growing
from trauma that we can all take.
As you'll soon learn Dr. Conti
is an exceptional communicator
and has a unique window
into the trauma and therapeutic process
that I know that all
of us can benefit from.
Before we begin,
I'd like to emphasize that
this podcast is separate
from my teaching and
research roles at Stanford.
It is however,
part of my desire and
effort to bring zero cost
to consumer information about science
and science related tools
to the general public.
In keeping with that theme,
I'd like to thank the
sponsors of today's podcast.
Our first sponsor is ROKA.
ROKA makes eyeglasses and sunglasses
that are of the absolute highest quality.
The company was founded by
two all American swimmers
from Stanford and everything about ROKA
eyeglasses and sunglasses
was designed with performance in mind.
I spent a lifetime working
on the visual system
and I can tell you that our
visual system has to contend
with a lot of different challenges.
For instance, when you
move from a shady area
to a brightly lit area,
your eyes in your brain
have to adjust in order
for you to be able to see clearly.
ROKA, eyeglasses and sunglasses
were designed with the biology
of the visual system in mind.
So you never notice those transitions.
They're very seamless.
You always see things
with perfect clarity.
The other terrific thing about ROKA
eyeglasses and sunglasses is
they are extremely lightweight.
Most of the time,
I can't even remember
that I'm wearing them.
I wear readers at night
and I wear sunglasses
sometimes in the daytime
when it is very brighter
or I'm driving and so on.
If you'd like to try ROKA
eyeglasses or sunglasses,
go to roka.com,
that's roka.com and enter the
code Huberman to save 20% off
on your first order.
Again, that's roka.com
and enter the code Huberman at checkout.
Today's podcast is also brought
to us by inside tracker.
Inside tracker is a
personalized nutrition platform
that analyzes data from your blood
and DNA to help you better
understand your body and help
you reach your health goals.
I've long been a believer in
getting regular blood work done
for the simple reason that
many of the factors that impact
our immediate and long-term health
can only be measured and assessed
with a quality blood test.
And nowadays with the
advent of modern DNA tests,
we can also get insight
into, for instance,
our biological age and
see how that compares
to our chronological age.
And of course,
despite what our birthday
cake screams back at us,
it is our biological
age that really matters.
If you're going to get blood
tests or DNA tests, however,
you need to be able to interpret the data.
And that's really where
inside tracker stands apart.
A lot of companies will give
you a DNA test or a blood test.
They'll send you values of
hormones, metabolic markers,
etcetera, but you don't know
what to do with those data.
InsideTrackeris a very
easy to use platform.
So when you get the numbers back,
you can click on any of the
numbers that either are in range
or out range, too low, too high, etcetera,
and it will direct you towards
specific behavioral tools,
so lifestyle factors, nutritional tools,
supplement tools, etcetera,
that can help you bring those numbers
into the ranges that are best for you,
which is really an exceptional
tool that makes all the blood
tests and DNA tests really
exceptionally powerful.
If you'd like to try Inside Tracker,
you can go to insidetracker.com/huberman
to get 20% off
any of InsideTracker's plans.
That's inside tracker.com/huberman
to get 20% off.
Today's episode is also
brought to us by Blinkist.
Blinkist is an app that has
thousands of non-fiction books
condensed down to just 15 minutes each
of key takeaways that you
can read or listen to,
to extract the most important
knowledge from those books.
I love reading physical books,
literally physical hard copies of books.
And I like listening to audio books.
However, I also like to revisit books
that I've read or listened to,
and sometimes I just want
to get the key points
or the key takeaways from a book
that I've never read or listened to.
Blinkist is terrific for all of that.
For instance, when researching
our episodes on sleep,
one of the books that I
read and found very valuable
is Matt Walker, professor
at UC Berkeley's book,
"Why We Sleep,"
I've read that book,
but then I wanted to also make sure
that I hit the key takeaways.
Blinkist was essential for that.
Other books that I've read
before and that I own and enjoy,
but I listened to the Blinkist
version of from time to time
are things like Tim
Ferris's "The 4-Hour Body"
or Tim Ferris's The 4-Hour Chef book,
both of which are excellent
or Nassim Taleb's "The Black Swan"
and there are many other titles as well.
Blinkist is also a great way
to finally get through many of the books
that you've been meaning to read,
but haven't had time for.
With Blinkist, you get
unlimited access to reader
or listen to a massive library
of condensed non-fiction books.
Right now, Blinkist has a special offer
just for our Huberman
lab podcast audience.
If you go to blinkist.com/huberman,
you can get a free seven day trial
and get 25% off a Blinkist
premier membership.
That's Blinkist spelled B-L-I-N-K-I-S-T,
blinkist.com/huberman to get 25% off
and a seven day free trial.
And now for my discussion
with Dr. Paul Conti.
Paul, thank you so much
for being here today.
- Thank you so much for having me.
- I've been looking forward to this
and I've received a ton
of questions about trauma,
about therapy,
about how to assess
where one is in their own
arc of problems and addressing
familial issues and relationship
issues and so forth.
If we could just start off very basic
and just get everyone oriented.
- Sure.
- How should we define trauma?
We all have hard experiences.
Some of them, we might
ruminate on more than others,
but what is trauma?
- To make the definition relevant,
I think we have to look at
trauma as not anything negative
that happens to us, right?
But something that
overwhelms our coping skills,
then leaves us different
as we move forward.
So it changes the way that
our brains function, right?
And then that changes evident in us
as we move forward through life.
- So how do we know if
we have trauma or not?
I've heard before everyone has trauma.
For instance, I've heard
that if we are a child
or when we are a child
and we request love from
a parent or attention
from a parent,
if they dismiss us that
that's a microtrauma,
is that overstating or unfair
to the real issue of trauma?
Do we all have trauma?
What are micro traumas?
What are macro traumas?
- Right, I think traumas
that we might categorize
as disappointments, right?
Or things that are are negative,
but not deeply impactful,
I think is not a helpful
definition, right?
I think the helpful definition
is something that rises
to the magnitude of really
changing us and something
that we can see both in how we behave.
We can see it in mood,
anxiety, behavior, sleep, physical health.
So we can identify it
and we can also see it in brain changes.
So the fact that we become,
say more hypervigilant, right?
More vigilant,
and then we can see that
different parts of the brain
are more active.
So that definition,
that definition captures how trauma,
if it rises to a certain
level, like what we would say,
trauma that makes a post
trauma syndrome, right?
Leaves us different,
I think is the helpful
definition of trauma
because it's a clinical definition, right?
It's changes in us as people
and we can map those changes
to identifiable shifts
in our brain function.
- So how do we know if we've
been changed by something?
I mean, I can think
back to childhood events
where some kid on the playground
or in the classroom said something,
I didn't like, something
negative about me.
I think most people can do that.
We have a great memory for the kid
that said something awful,
or the parent or teacher
that said something awful
that really felt like it hurt
us or at least stuck with us.
So clearly one's brain,
my brain in this example has been changed
by that event such that I remember it,
but how do we know if something
has actually changed the way that we are?
Because of course we don't
know how we would be otherwise.
- Right, right.
- That's difficult, right.
It's doable, but it's
difficult because the response,
so if the trauma rises to the
level of changing our brains
and I don't just mean, like
we have a new memory, right?
So we can have memories
of something that was negative, right?
And in that sense,
it changes the brain because
now there's something we can call to mind,
but it doesn't change the
functioning of the brain, right?
If trauma rises to the level
of changing the functioning of our brains,
then there's almost always
a reflex of guilt and shame
around the trauma that can lead us
and often leads us to bury,
right, to avoid it, right?
To feel that now there's
something negative inside of me
and it feels shameful
or it feels like no one
else would accept it, right?
So, what happens is people tend to avoid
looking at the change in them,
which is exactly the opposite
of what needs to be done, right?
The idea of in a viral pandemic, right?
We want to stay away from one
another and isolate, right?
But with the trauma epidemic we need,
we need to communicate with other people.
We need to communicate and
put words to what's going on
inside of us.
And very often a, a person knows, I mean,
I've done so much clinical
work over about 20 years,
that has focused on trauma.
And a lot of the times
the person knows, right?
But they're not admitting to themselves
because they're afraid of it, right?
They don't know what to do,
but if they start talking,
then they'll talk about
the event or the situation.
It could be something acute,
or it could be something chronic,
that really has been
harmful to them, right?
And then they feel different afterwards.
Like, oh, after that,
I started thinking differently,
feeling differently,
but that doesn't always happen.
Sometimes it's a process of exploration
through dialogue, right?
Whether it's written
or whether it's spoken
of the person,
so of exploring the changes
inside of themselves,
maybe changes to their self-talk inside,
changes to their thoughts about the world
and whether they can navigate
safely and readily in it.
And you know, it anchors
as I talk about this,
the example I'll use at times
is the example of my own life,
where, you know, when I was much younger
in my early twenties,
my younger brother took
his life by suicide.
And the response of guilt and shame
and hiding all of it inside of me was,
it's very dramatic,
but I wasn't acknowledging it, right?
'Cause I didn't know what to do about it.
And I felt guilty and I felt
responsible and I felt ashamed.
So there was an avoidance inside of me.
And then I wasn't saying to
myself, hey, before this,
like you thought that
you could be effective
and you could make your way in the world.
And you know, if you were a
good person and you worked hard,
you could make a difference, right?
And then afterwards, I
thought, I can't get anywhere.
The world's against me.
And I felt like, oh my,
my options are all gone.
And you know,
I was like 24 years old, right?
So, I didn't see that
the change was in me,
but I was taking care of myself poorly.
Like there was enough
going on that was unhealthy
that I couldn't avoid the
realization that like, hey,
I'm different now and in
these ways that are automatic.
My reflex to, can I make
my way in the world?
Can I have a good life?
Can I be happy?
My reflex is to that we're all different.
And they were coming through
the lens of heightened anxiety,
heightened vigilance, a sense of guilt,
a sense of shame and a
sense of non belonging
in the world
and was ultimately good and
helpful people around me
and my own realization.
And hey, things are not going well, right?
That led me to then get some help
and to be able to talk about it
and realize like, oh my gosh,
I need to face these things
that are going on inside of me.
- From a psychoanalytic psychological,
and maybe even a neuroscience
perspective, two questions.
Why do you think that
when we experience trauma,
these things that we call
guilt and shame surface?
Everything you're telling
me is that in the end,
that's not adaptive.
- Hmm.
- [Paul] Why would we be built that way?
- Right, right.
- So that's the first question.
And then the second question is,
how should we conceptualize
guilt and shame?
I think that we hear guilt.
We hear shame.
How should we think about it?
I mean, those emotions must
exist in us for some reason,
but in this case, it seems like they,
they don't serve us well.
So maybe it that order
or in reverse order,
what is guilt, really?
What is shame really?
And why is it that we seem
to be reflexively wired
to feel guilty and feel
ashamed when that's the exact
opposite of what we need to
do in the case of trauma?
- Right, right.
No, I think these are great questions.
And I don't think anyone
knows the answers for sure.
But my read of all of that
is that there's something
adaptive that has happened in us
through evolution that
now becomes maladaptive
in the way we live in
the modern world, right?
So if you think of through
most of human development,
people weren't living that long, right?
And the idea was to survive and reproduce.
So, traumatic things that happened to us,
it would make sense for
them to stay with us, right?
So if you ate a new food and got really,
really sick, you better
remember that, right?
If you see someone from
the group of people,
a couple miles away, right?
And one of those people
attacks you, right?
It's like, you better remember that.
So, the traumatic things
that are sort of emblazoned in our brain
are built to last, right?
Things that are positive will generate
some emotion inside of us,
but things that are profoundly negative
are much more likely to stay with us.
And I think that that was adaptive, right?
When all of that was
about survival, right?
And I think the same thing is
true with say shame, right?
So I think here, it makes
sense to talk a little bit
and actually I'm interested
your thoughts about this, right?
That the limbic system, right?
So the system often is called
the emotion system, right?
In our brains has actually of course
varying function, right?
And one aspect is affect, right?
So affect is aroused in us,
which I think the meaning then
is it's created in us
without our choice, right?
So if we're walking down the road
and someone jumps in front
of us or pushes us, right?
Then there's a response
of fear, anger, right?
Heart starts beating faster,
more blood to the muscles,
we're getting ready to fight, right?
Or run, right?
And then we become aware of it, right?
So, the aroused affect in
us is also about survival
and it has a very deep impact upon us
and shame is an aroused affect.
So it can be raised in
us without our choice
and it's very powerful,
which if you think about that
is an extremely strong deterrent, right?
So if you had, you know,
imagine a tribe or a
group of people, right?
That are sheltered
together, and, you know,
someone eats half the food
at night or something, right?
And like there's a very
negative response, right?
And that person feels shame
because shame is so powerful
to control behavior, right?
So the way that trauma
can change our brains
and stay with us in a way
that says, be more vigilant,
look at the world in a different way,
act more defensively, right?
And how that links to shame and to guilt,
and then guilt in,
guilt becomes what gets
called feeling technically
where we relate the aroused
affect to ourselves, right?
So, shame the aroused affect and guilt,
the next step, right?
When the shame gets related
to self are such profound
behavioral interventions
and deterrents, right?
That you can see,
I think how evolutionarily
kind of all makes sense
if we're fighting for survival
and we're an elder statesman
if we make it to 20, right?
This makes sense.
But it doesn't make sense in a world
where we live much longer, right?
We navigate in all
sorts of different ways.
And there's so much coming at
us that can be traumatizing.
I mean, if you think
about the news, right?
I mean, how many times have
I written a prescription
for someone that says no more news, right?
- You've actually written
those prescriptions?
- Oh, yes, yes.
So glance at the news,
look at the news for news,
anything going on I need to know, right?
But what are people doing is looking at it
and they're clicking and they're clicking.
And there's a sense of
being like enthralled
in a very frightening way with the horrors
that are in front of us.
And it shows how yes,
trauma can come through acute
things that happen to us.
Trauma can come through chronic
things, chronic denigration,
whether it's based upon
socioeconomic status,
immigration status,
race, religion, sexuality,
gender identity, these
chronic traumas, right?
Of being denigrated by
the society around us,
or treated as less than
can change the brain.
But vicarious experiences can too, right?
And we know this is not theoretical.
We know that the changes in the brain
can come from vicarious experiences too,
which is why people who
are glued to the news
and then feeling like, oh my goodness,
like what is happening?
The mothers in the Ukraine who've
lost babies in the war.
And like, there are things
that are so terrifying
that if we spend so much time with that,
it has a similar effect.
So our brains are built
to change from trauma,
but not in the way we experience trauma
and not in the way that we live life
in terms of the nature of living life
and the duration of life
in the modern world,
where these traumas that happen to us
are often so bad for us
because they change how
our brain is functioning.
And then our entire orientation
to the world is different
and that could be for,
years and years and decades and decades.
It brings so much misery and suffering
and at times it brings death.
If you think about a hundred
thousand overdose deaths
in this country in a year, 100,000,
I mean where is a,
so much of that arising from
is a person who's treated
addiction very intensively
over many years.
I think that, well,
I feel sure that the majority of addiction
that I see and treat arises,
ultimately the roots of it are
in trauma and are in trying
to soothe something that's
stuck inside that the person
isn't letting outside because
of the guilt and shame,
but it's running around in their head
and tormented by it.
And now there's a pool for,
for these drugs or sometimes
medicines to soothe.
So, the opiates
that were given after
a minor surgery, right?
Are like, okay, yeah,
they help the pain for the minor surgery,
but what they're really helping
is the pain inside, right?
But that very quickly turns
into addiction, danger, risk.
And we see that over and over again
and not in a theoretical way.
Like I see that in people
who have been in my practice
with addiction, arising from trauma
who have subsequently died.
So it's sort of, writ
large in our existence,
in the modern world.
- Incredible to me that
this is the way it works.
What I mean by that is
this idea that I've heard about before.
I think it was a Freudian concept
of a repetition compulsion.
- Yes.
- That this is what boggles my mind,
as I'm hearing this,
something happens to us or we
observe something traumatic.
And instead of acknowledging that
and trying to distance from it,
there seems to be a
reflex of shame and guilt
in many cases and stuffing it away
and then a repetition of behaviors
to continue to try and just stuff it away.
- [Paul] Yes.
- Like you're trying
to pack, I don't know,
recently I was packing a home
and trying to get a sleeping
bag back into the bag.
it seems like it's always
trying mushroom out the top,
this kind of thing.
It takes a lot of ongoing effort.
And at the same time that
if this thing really exists,
this repetition compulsion,
people will return over and over again
to the kinds of scenarios
or at least the kinds
of emotional states that
look just like the trauma.
- [Paul] Yes.
- Or resemble it in some way.
So the question I have for you is,
is the repetition compulsion a real thing?
And why would we be wired that way?
My understanding of this
concept of the repetition
compulsion is that we all
want to solve our traumas.
- [Paul] Yes.
- And it allows us to put
ourselves into micro or again,
macro versions of that
over and over again.
We get to run the
experiment again and again.
- Right.
- In an attempt to solve it.
- In the case of taking a drug
that it's clear certain
drugs like opioids,
it's clear how that would not allow us,
to deal with it, right?
- [Paul] Yeah.
- It's just masking the emotional state.
But why is it for instance that somebody
who experiences sexual trauma,
then places themselves into circumstances
of more sexual trauma?
Why is it that somebody who
is in an abusive relationship
goes on to have a second and
third or fourth verbally,
or physically abusive relationship?
Yeah, I mean, on the
face of it, you just go,
that makes no sense.
And yet we see this over
and over and over again.
- Yes, the first thing I would say
about the validity of the repetition
compulsion concept, right?
Is a strong yes.
Like, yes, we see that over and over.
It's not necessarily in everyone, but boy,
it is in a lot of people
who have suffered trauma.
And I think there's a very
good reason on the face,
on the surface of it, it's
like, it makes no sense.
But then if we think,
well, how does the brain,
how does our brains
actually function, right?
We're sort of trained at
least in Western society,
I think, to think of ourselves
as logical creatures, right?
That like, oh, we're logical.
And ultimately everything in
us can just boil down to logic.
And if we think about it enough,
we're going to understand how
to make the right decisions,
which is completely not true, right?
The limbic system, right?
The emotion system so
to speak inside of us
always Trump's logic, right?
If you think about,
does it ever make sense to
run into a burning building?
I mean, logic says no, right?
But if someone you love is
in the burning building,
people run right in, right?
Because the limbic system says, yes.
So when logic and emotion
come head to head,
emotion wins all the time.
If emotion is powerful enough,
it will always win.
And so the limbic system is
so important and the limbic
system does not care about the
clock or the calendar, right?
And that's the answer.
And also, say why
to the repetition compulsion.
So the limbic system doesn't know like,
oh, it's now, it's today.
It's may, it's 2022.
It just doesn't care at all, right?
So how I would relate that
to the repetition compulsion
is when people are repeating,
what they're trying to do is
to make things right, right?
With the idea that if we
can repeat the situation
and make it right, it will
fix everything, right?
Which makes perfect sense if we think,
well, where is that
concept coming from, right?
It's coming from the
emotional part of the brain
that wants relief from
suffering of the trauma
and does not understand
the clock or the calendar.
So if I can solve something now,
I will also solve something
in the past, right?
Which is why I can't
tell you how many times
I've sat with someone and say,
we're starting to do therapy, right?
And a person will say, oh
gosh, like I know, look,
you just can't help me, right?
I mean, you know,
my last seven relationships
have been abusive, right?
And I'll say back something
sometimes like, well,
if you tell me that you've
had seven relationships
that have been abusive in different ways,
I'll agree with you.
Like, I only say that,
'cause that's never what
someone says, right?
But I think what you're going
to tell me is you've kind of had
the same relationship seven times.
It's not seven things, it's one, right?
And that's always, I
don't think one time yet
that has failed to be the case.
And that's how, so if you think about it,
that's how we start to
elucidate what's going on.
So they make the light bulb that goes off.
Like I have not had seven
different abusive relationships.
I have had one that I
have repeated seven times
and now we start getting
to what's really going on
and what needs to happen,
that person needs to face
what happened in that original
abusive relationship
and it always comes down to
the same sort of concepts,
of the person feeling terrified
while the abuse was going on,
feeling guilty, feeling
ashamed, feeling like, oh,
they brought it on themselves.
They deserve it.
They don't deserve anything better, right?
Because the brain is trying
to make sense of it, right?
Or I thought I could make that
okay, but I couldn't, right?
And then there's more
guilt and more shame.
And if that's stuck inside of someone,
like that's bundled up inside of someone,
like a medical abscess inside a person,
a walled off infection inside the body,
this is the same concept in the brain,
then of course the limb system
is going to want to fix that.
And it fixes it by trying to
let's recreate that situation
and make it right this
time and that's, I mean,
I think that one of the best examples
of how the right approach of
how like, let's look at that,
let's talk about that, right?
What's really going on there,
wait, who should feel guilty
and ashamed is the person who is a abused
or the person who is abusing, right?
And we can get it what's
going on inside the person.
And that's what changes that.
And then the eighth relationship
can be entirely different
than the first seven, right?
And I see that all the time.
I mean, this isn't esoteric or soft.
Like I see that play out
clinically over and over again.
And why do things get better?
Because we go to the
trauma and we unlock it.
It's not hidden inside where
it can control things, right?
We bring it to the surface
and we can take away its power.
- I keep hearing in this narrative
that so much of our
reflexive response to trauma,
both emotional and in the
repetition compulsion in terms
of behaviors is about
some very deep attempt
to change the past.
- Yes.
- And in fact, in an offline conversation,
I recall you saying
something about this, that,
the number of behaviors
and thoughts and avoidance
of behaviors and avoidance of thoughts
that human beings put in to trying
and change the past.
- [Paul] Right.
- Is remarkable and eerie and maladaptive,
it sounds like.
- [Paul] Yes.
- And that really stuck with me
because I think we all want
to feel like we're in control
of our future and how
we feel in the moment.
And to some extent, it
works for a brief while.
There's this thing that
happened and it's just,
it evokes some internal arousal
and then you have to know
what to do with that arousal.
And I think for many people,
including myself, there's
this fundamental question.
Okay, the thought about the
thing, the event or events,
plural, evokes this arousal,
this internal states, makes some people
feel sleepy and exhausted.
Other people feel really anxious.
Other people feel angry.
I mean that arousal has all
these different dimensions
as you know,
and then there's this question
of like what to do with it.
- [Paul] Yes.
And I'd love to hear a maybe even just
a top contour prescriptive of
what do I, what does one do?
I'll even just put myself
in it, what do I do?
So I'm feeling upset about something.
Should I feel like my options
are healthy catharsis.
I could tell the story, feel it.
I could.
I can pack it down.
We hear that it's bad to pack it down.
But of course one has
to be functional in life
and deal with things.
And we have responsibilities at work
and relational responsibilities, etcetera.
We need to sleep at night.
So catharsis, healthy catharsis,
packing it down at the other extreme.
Telling the story.
And yet I think a lot of people
are afraid to tell the story
because in that telling
there is perhaps a
reemergence of the arousal.
- Yes.
- The arousal can become greater, I mean.
- Is that what people mean when they say
things are going to get
worse before they get better?
I mean, so I guess,
the simple version of this
long-winded question is,
it's clear we need to
confront these things.
We can't change the past by,
a reflexive response isn't
going to do that efficiently.
And so how do we deal with arousal?
How does one take what they feel
inside about something shameful?
What do you do with it in a moment?
And does that have to be done
in the presence of a skilled
trained therapist or
as I'm driving to work
in the morning and something comes up,
I can't deal with this
right now comes to mind,
what do I do?
Do I deal with it right then?
I know this is a big
multidimensional question.
- Yes.
- But I think it's the one
that a lot of people grapple with.
We want to deal with things.
How do we deal with that internal arousal?
- Yeah, yeah.
We so often try and change
the trauma of the past
in order to control the future
and what that really adds up
to is the trauma of the past
dominates our present, right?
And it doesn't have to be that way.
And remember, we're talking about traumas
that rise to the level
of changing the brain.
So as you're saying,
that involves re-experience,
it involves hyper vigilance,
increased arousal.
It changes in mood states,
changes in anxiety, changes in sleep,
changes in behavior.
So these are all changes that in a sense,
push towards dominating
our present, right?
And then we're not really
living in the present, right.
As we're trying to control the future.
We're not going to do a great
job of controlling our future
if we're not really living
in the present, right?
And so the way to come at
that again in the moment,
if we're saying, okay, in the moment,
if I need to fall asleep, right?
I might say, okay, let me try
and put that out of my mind.
Let me try and thought redirect.
So there's short term
strategies that can let us be
functional in the
context of these changes.
But the answer is to go look
directly at that thing, right?
Look at that trauma, explore
that trauma, and sure.
That can be done with a professional.
And sometimes that's what makes sense,
but not always, right?
Sometimes it can be done
by talking to another person, right?
Writing it down, right?
Look at what's going on inside of me,
that my mind is so stuck to this.
Let's explore that because
it's almost as if we're,
we're so afraid,
so often of looking at the
trauma that has changed us,
that we'll look anywhere.
But at that, right?
It's like hidden in a closet
and we'll shine the light everywhere else,
but we're not going to open that door.
And that's where
people will say that same
as I've heard over and over.
And I myself have thought
this at times like, oh,
if I talk about that,
I'm going to start crying
and never stop, right?
Or I'm going to just fall apart, right?
Which is never what happens.
No one ever starts crying
and never stops, right?
What ends up happening
is when the person puts
words to it, right?
It could be in writing,
it could be talking to a trusted other
or with a therapist, right?
Things start to change.
I mean, just the fact that
you can talk about it,
you can put words to it
and other people don't recoil, right?
I mean, how many times has someone said
something for the first time, right?
And when they're telling
me about the trauma,
there's such an anxious,
like looking like as if I'm going to be,
I'm going to recoil from it, right?
Meaning I'm going to
recoil from them, right?
And then there's a sense of
surprise if the person says,
well, you know, I was abused by
this coach when I was a kid, right?
And there's not a, okay,
there's not a response of recoiling.
You can see the change and
people will say a lot, like, wow.
Like, I can't believe like you can like,
hear me say that and
be okay with it, right?
I mean, so you think about
what's going on inside of them.
Like how, what a sense
of shame, a sense of,
this is something awful about
me for people to recoil from
and it's just not true,
but here's where trauma
is, it's insidious, right?
And it's pervasive, right?
Because if that convinces us
to continually hide it away,
then how do we explore it?
That example of the person who says, okay,
I was abused by a coach
when I was a child.
I mean, I'm thinking of a
couple, very real cases, right?
People that I've taken care of.
And once they start talking about it,
then they start talking about how, ,
they were just innocent kids, right?
And like, they didn't know.
And like, they really
wanted to be on the team
where this coach was
treating them as special.
And now they can look at
themselves from the outside, right?
They can look at themselves
like they would look
at someone else, right?
You think it's so easy for us
to see what's real and true,
if it's someone else, right?
If you ask someone,
what do you think of someone
who's 10, 11 years old,
who's abused and manipulated
and abused by an adult?
And you say, oh my goodness,
I feel compassion for that person, right?
But if it's us right then, oh no,
it's guilt and shame and
we have to hide it away.
And when the person starts looking at it,
they can sort of see it from the outside.
And it starts to take the
energy out of it, right?
Then, well, who should
feel guilty about that?
Who's done something wrong?
And like, so now the
conceptions come together,
which is often a reflexive,
that was my fault.
Oh, I did it.
I went back to it.
I still stayed on the team.
I went back next season, right?
I let it happen again, right?
All the guilt and shame inside the person
gets juxtaposed to like,
what really happened there?
And then they say, right.
I was a terrified child, right?
I didn't understand at all.
And they can come to
a place of compassion.
And now we are working
against the guilt and shame.
And if the person cries about
it, then it's great, right?
I mean, crying is one
of the best coping mechanisms we have.
It doesn't hurt us.
And it lets us grieve things.
Yeah, we can't grieve if there's guilt
and shame inside of us,
it just blocks grief, right?
We have to,
there has to be a clean slate
in a sense in order to feel sadness.
And then you see that it
shifts from anxiety, anger,
and frustration, usually
directed towards the self,
the guilt and shame towards,
towards being able to process
it and being able to bring
to bear some compassion
and being able to direct
the negative emotions,
so to speak where they're
warranted and my goodness,
the changes that happen.
I mean, it's not like people
are miraculously cured, right?
But it's remarkable how
just getting it out there
and having like one hour
of talking like that,
like what we're talking about now
can leave a person
feeling immensely better.
- It seems to me in hearing this,
that there's this weird
wiring that we have,
because what I'm hearing is
when traumas happen to us
or we observe them,
what we need to do most
is to confront those
and the emotions around that directly.
- [Paul] Yes.
But instead our system
defaults to guilt, shame.
- [Paul] Yes.
- And trying to hide it.
And this repetition
compulsion of placing us back
into things similar to those traumas.
Or even maybe even worse traumas.
- [Paul] Yes.
- In an attempt to resolve it.
It's like the most maladaptive.
- [Andrew] Wiring diagram.
I could possibly think of.
- Yes.
- Emotional and presumably
physiological wiring diagram.
- [Paul] Yes.
And this notion of trying to change
the past by doing things now,
when the exact opposite is
what's going to be beneficial
also seems like the complete,
the whole system seems
completely backwards.
And I'm, I'm chuckling as I say this,
not because I'm amused it's
because I'm just baffled once
again at how our wiring can
often not serve us well.
But it raises an,
what I think is an important
and interesting question,
which is earlier, you
were talking about how
people will seek out media
that's really disturbing.
They'll traumatize and
re-traumatize themselves
on a daily basis.
So that could be viewed as
the repetition compulsion
or the person will have
the same relationship
with seven different,
same abusive relationship
with seven different partners
in sequence seems terrible.
And yet,
as I say this,
it also is becoming clear
to me how this almost seems
like a poor, but desperate attempt
to resolve it in some way.
- Yes.
- And so the fork in the road,
if I understand correctly,
is to really get to the seed incident,
really get to the thing
that started it all,
as opposed to repeating it all.
- [Paul] Yes.
- Does that have to be done in
the presence of a therapist?
Is there a benefit to
taking a walk and thinking
about these things,
breaking down and crying,
if that's what's necessary
or feeling angrier,
if that's what comes up?
The reason I ask it this
way is because I worry,
I'll just speak to my own experience,
I worry that in reactivating
or touching into the
emotions around something
that is itself a form of
the repetition compulsion,
because you're feeling it all over again.
- [Paul] Right.
- You're not seeking out
something to evoke that feeling.
So I realize this is a little bit
of a circular argument, right?
Or question.
But I think it's one that
I really struggle with
in trying to parse all the,
the outcome based
therapies that I hear about
and the recommendations that people make.
I mean, how should we conceptualize this?
Something happens.
Sounds like we need to deal
with that thing directly.
Do we need to do that with somebody else?
Can we do that on our own?
If we're,
we don't have resources and
we have to do it on our own,
can't hire someone, can't
pay someone to work with us.
- [Paul] Right.
- How do we do that in a way
that isn't retraumatizing ourself
in a major way, or in a minor way.
How do we know where we
are in that landscape?
- Right.
Again, those are, I
think, great questions.
And I think it starts
with real introspection.
When things are bouncing
around in our minds,
often, it's very, non-productive right?
It's the same thing over and over again,
and that's not helpful for us, right?
So there's an idea which sometimes
gets called an observing ego, right?
The ability to stop and look
at what's going on inside of ourselves.
And so if we're just thinking about it
and we're thinking in the same way,
we sort of, in a sense,
always think about it,
then all we're doing is
reinforcing the trauma, right?
But if we can distance
enough to be like, huh, it's,
I'm interested in what's
going on inside of me, right?
I can think of a certain person
who really loves music.
I mean, and at some point
in our therapy work,
I learned like she was taking long drives,
but the, the radio wasn't on.
And I was like, well,
what what's going on, right?
And I asked,
and what was going on
is she was running over
and over again in her head, like,
I'm a loser, I'm a loser, right?
And she didn't want the music
on because the music would
drown out what she felt she
had to say to herself, right?
And it was that like, wow,
that's interesting, right?
And then her ability to
observe that and to think,
why am I doing that when
it comes into her mind?
Like, what does that trace to,
when did I start doing that?
Like I say, you know,
I'm saying it for a point
of exaggeration, we're like,
nobody comes out of the womb
programmed to think I'm a loser, right?
So we don't think that
when we're born, right?
So where does that come from?
Then, we can think in ways
that allow us to have new thoughts, right?
That we weren't having,
It's not just bouncing
around in our minds.
And if we speak or write,
there are even more mechanisms
that come online in our brains, right?
That are then sort of
monitoring mechanisms.
We think in a different way,
if we're using words, right?
And we are better able often
to bring in that observing ego,
like what's going on inside of me?
So it can be very helpful to think,
it can be helpful to talk to someone,
to a trusted other, you
know, friend, family,
clergy to write, I mean,
these are things that can be done
without expending any resources, right?
And sometimes it can make
really a big difference, right?
It was a way, when did
I start thinking that?
And like, interestingly,
in this case, okay,
we did it in therapy,
but it became very clear what
that was rooted to, right?
And then in the therapy,
which was still relatively young,
but we'd done several sessions
and we weren't talking at all
about what we needed to talk about, right?
But that's what got us to
what we needed to talk about.
And when did that start,
and now we're in that same
place of exploring that
and what was the reflex to it
and the sense of guilt and sense of shame.
And it's where all of that came from
that just got boiled down
to I'm a loser, right?
Which this person didn't
even have in their mind.
Like, I didn't think about
myself that way, right?
And that's is so interesting, right?
That our memories don't in
and of themselves have meaning
it's like they're flat
or colorless, right?
And they're colored in by the emotions
that we attach to them, right?
So, the idea that certain memories now,
before the trauma were changed, right?
By the trauma.
So I tell the story,
sometimes of a person
who like won an award
when they were in high
school that they thought was,
oh my gosh, like it shows,
like I can do it, right?
I get out there, that after trauma,
they saw the award with the
negative emotion attached to it.
That was like, oh,
it was given to me and
I didn't deserve it.
And almost it was mocking.
Like, it was going to be the
greatest achievement in my life
and I was 17 or so, and to
have someone think like,
that's not how they felt
about that at the time.
It's the trauma that
changed, the self talk,
the internal state going forward
and talking about miraculous
in a negative way,
also changed that going backward, right?
And when we can really look at that,
like where did that come from?
And we can start
unraveling it, it changes.
So in those cases, you
know, often it's helpful
to have a good therapist,
it's not always necessary.
And it certainly, it's not
always possible, right?
So we need other strategies.
And some of those,
I write about some of those in the book
of how can we sort of get at trauma
without those formalized mechanisms.
And sometimes if the symptoms
are significant enough,
like we really do need to
talk to somebody professional
who can help us get to
the root of the trauma.
And there's so many times,
that's the answer to what's
going on with people.
People I've seen have had
five residential stays.
I'm not exaggerating this,
for mental health reasons,
for substance reasons,
and no one's ever taken
a trauma history, right?
And then when you take a
trauma history, you say,
well, that's obviously where
this is all coming from, right?
Like that's when the drug
use started truly thereafter,
the negative self talk
and the negative feelings
that led to the drug use.
Then you go after the trauma
and you can change things.
Whereas trying to change
things without looking,
introspecting, talking about the trauma,
I think of course was futile.
- Do you think that people
can start to have negative fantasies?
I mean, you mentioned this woman
who would take these long
drives to berate herself.
I'm not familiar with that, but I'll,
I'll give a little bit of
personal disclosure here.
I've felt several times in my life
that I will start to create a narrative
about something that truly hasn't happened
about something terrible
that somebody is going to do.
- [Paul] Yes.
- That's going to upset me.
- And for the longest time,
I wonder why am I doing this?
And I have a couple ideas about why, one,
is that I was attempting
to just avoid thinking
about other things.
It's just, you know, anger is such
an attractive emotional force in this.
It's an attracting, it's not attractive.
We don't like it.
And yet, oftentimes anger is a great way
to replace feeling something else.
- [Paul] Yes.
- Feeling sad or having to come up
or to do work or to do something useful.
So it has this kind of a like
gravitational force to it.
That was one idea.
The other idea was in imagining
kind of worst outcomes,
then actually that relationship were,
could actually seem a
lot better in reality.
- Hm hm.
- [Andrew] It's almost like
creating this negative contrast.
- Yes.
It's like, oh, well
then it's not that bad.
And then the third possibility
is I have no idea why,
but it seemed like a reflex.
And I spent some time thinking about it.
I can't say I've resolved it completely,
but why would somebody
have a narrative or a default
narrative when driving
or when walking of I'm just
going to spend some time
and think about how terrible
this thing is going to turn out
or how someone's going to upset me
or harm me or how terrible I am.
It seems, again, like
maladaptive thinking,
maladaptive wiring.
And yet I have to assume
that it serves some purpose.
- Yeah, yeah.
I mean, I think there are three factors
there and they're all bad.
And I think you spoke to at
least two of them, right?
They I think speak so powerfully
to how insidious trauma
is and how these are real
brain changes inside of us.
So I would say that the
three factors, punishment,
avoidance and control, right?
So the trauma inside of us,
that makes guilt and shame.
So often, so often leads
to a desire to punish oneself, right?
And the idea that, oh, that was my fault.
Or I deserve that.
Well, what do we do if something
is someone's fault and someone
now deserves punishment, right?
I mean, we we punish them, right?
We send 'em to jail, we
give them a fine, right?
We punish them.
And so what, what we do is
punish ourselves, right?
And if we tell ourselves we're a loser
or this awful thing is
going to happen, right?
Then part of what we're
doing is saying to ourselves,
see, right, you deserve that.
You're not going to have
anything better, right?
It's a negative.
It's a very negative
way that the brain tries
to make us in a sense,
to do better by hurting
us more for the things
that we couldn't and
shouldn't have been able to,
weren't expected to control
in the first place, right?
The second is distraction.
As you said, anger,
that kind of fantasy can distract us
from affect feeling and emotion.
That can be much more negative.
Anger, it can be more gratifying
than certainly than guilt or shame,
although guilt or shame can
serve a punishment purpose.
But if anger is directed also
towards ourselves, right,
then it can serve punishment too.
So punishment, avoidance,
and the sense of control
that if you think ahead
to something awful,
that you're imagining is going to happen,
well, maybe that will
let you avoid it, right?
I mean, you can see the
brain here in a sense,
really confused.
I mean, part of the brain wants to punish.
part of the brain doesn't
want to think about it at all
and part of the brain
wants to make it better.
And then how all of that resolves,
if we're not aware that,
hey, this is in the context of our brains
being deeply impacted by trauma.
So what's going on here
is all maladaptive, right?
'Cause these negative
fantasies of the future,
they may help us feel better
about something in the present,
but they don't help us make
anything better, right?
They don't help us make anything better.
So this is kind of the sequela.
This is where trauma and
all this reflexive stuff
that happens after trauma
ultimately lead us.
And you can see how we get lost,
how I've seen over and
over again in my own life,
in the lives of other people,
how man we get stuck in those situations
and that's why I see people sometimes.
This has been going on for
30 years, 40 years, right?
And it's just been going on
over and over and over again
because there's no natural
end to any of this, right?
Unless we,
we look at it in a different way,
that we have knowledge and
information like, whoa,
this isn't the way it has to be.
Let me bring a novel perspective to this.
It doesn't change on its own.
- I'm struck by your statement
that these thoughts or behaviors
can make us feel better,
but they don't actually
make anything better.
In that way,
this mode of imagining terrible outcomes
starts to immediately
seem like taking opioids.
You feel better in the moment,
but it doesn't actually
make anything better.
And it probably makes things worse.
- Yes.
- And just a question of how much worse
and in what direction, yes.
And so I just want to just
pause on that concept,
because I think that concept
of makes us feel better,
but doesn't make anything better.
I think it answers an earlier question
about what seems to be a totally
maladaptive wiring diagram.
We need to confront the thing,
but we don't want to go into
the repetition compulsion.
So it's a knife edge there,
to navigate through trauma.
- [Paul] Yes.
- Working with a very skilled
clinician like yourself,
I think is the ideal
circumstance for people.
And of course there are people
who can't access support
from somebody, for whatever reason.
You've talked about journaling.
- Hmm, yes.
- As a useful tool.
Could you maybe highlight
some of the other things that
people can do on their own.
And then I'd also like to talk about
what makes for a good therapist.
What should people look for
for those that are seeking therapy,
especially nowadays when a lot of therapy
is being done remotely, but
let's just start with the,
let's just call them self-generated
or zero cost sorts of things,
journaling being the first
and then what are some of the others
and what kind of structure
would you recommend
someone put around journaling,
carry a journal around all
day and jot things down
as they come up or sit down
and spend an hour writing
in complete sentences,
for instance.
- Yeah.
If I could add something
to what you had just said
before the question, right?
That we have these short-term
coping mechanisms in us, right?
And in a way it makes sense, right?
If we find ourselves in
just terrible situations,
then a short-term coping mechanism
can get us through them, right?
So our brains are built that way
and that's part of survival too, right?
And whether now in the modern
world, whether it's food,
it's drugs, it's sex, it's alcohol, right?
Or it's negative thoughts, right?
This is short-term soothing.
Even the negative thoughts,
And anger is short-term soothing
at the expense of long-term change, right?
And that's where addictive
pathways can come into play.
And that's where, again, our,
how we're built
evolutionarily for survival,
doesn't help us, you know, in
the way humans have evolved.
Like we haven't lived this way throughout,
99.9% something percent
of human history, right?
So we're not adapted to this.
So I want to just make a point of saying
that about the short-term soothing
at the expense of any of long-term change,
And then the question you had
asked about say journaling
or what can we do that's
outside of professional.
I think the hallmark of it
has to be bringing new eyes to it, right?
Like thinking about self with a curiosity,
instead of just a simple
automaticity or repetition, right?
Like, why am I thinking about this?
When did this start?
Why is this in me?
Right?
Whether it's words or
whether we're writing,
that's so important.
So I think for journaling,
it depends on the person.
I mean, we don't want
somebody carrying around
a journal all day,
if then there's a compulsion to,
I need to write about everything
that's going on in my mind, right?
Like that might be good to okay.
Write a little bit at night, right?
Or someone who might think,
sometimes this really comes
into my mind in a strong way
and it could be unpredictable, right?
I want to have the journal with me.
So, ah, that thing is back in my mind now,
let me write about it, right?
Because then putting words to it
and then being able to
read those words, right?
And when people read,
even do a little bit of journaling
and they read like, oh,
I thought again about
how I'm a terrible person
who can't have a good life,
because I was in such a bad car accident
or because that person attacked me
or because when I was in school,
I was bullied because I looked different
than everyone else, right?
Or acted different from everyone else.
Wow, to actually see that written out.
It's a little bit of that,
it's a little bit of that.
Like when you're saying it to someone
as if it were someone else, right?
Because now there's
enough distance from it.
Like I'm looking at the
words I wrote, right?
That we get some distance
and we can start to integrate
some of the, not just the compassion,
but integrating compassion
and logic, right?
Of like, okay.
I feel a sense of compassion
now, wait, what does this mean?
What really happened here, right?
And gosh, I did start thinking
differently after that.
I started, that's where
this came from, right?
That's why I'm saying this,
it's those kind of
revelations that we can have
through again, the written or spoken word.
And I think again, that
involves a trusted other,
or writing, right?
And I think that those
are ways we can do this,
where we bring some de novo
perspective to something
that often has been bouncing
around inside of us.
And it's amazing to me that,
I can see such intelligent
empathically, attuned people
who've had the same thing
running over and over again
in their mind for years.
And it just points out that our brains
don't automatically
say, hey, wait a second.
I've been spinning wheels
here for a long, long time.
Like, was there another
way to look at this?
We need something from the outside,
which can just be knowledge, right?
Which is why I think what we're doing here
or the reason I wrote the
book that I wrote was like,
apprehending this like
amazing surprise to me, right?
Which is like, wow,
like some huge percentage
of everything I'm treating
is rooted in trauma and the
opacity of trauma, right?
Which is why we don't see
that, oh, the depression,
the panic attacks, the
life change, the addiction,
the maladaptive choices like, oh,
this is all coming from
trauma because it hides itself
in that opacity.
So we need a de novo perspective
if we're doing it on our own.
And we need that if we're
doing it in therapy,
which might link like finding
the right therapist, right?
Which is also part of your question.
- Yeah, yeah I definitely want to know
about how to assess and
find the right therapist.
Before we cover that, however,
something came up in the
course of your answer.
I can immediately relate to this idea that
certain behaviors are really maladaptive
and are stuffing things
down or avoiding the topic
is problematic and bringing a curiosity
and an introspection and
almost a third personing
of the experience
that we've had in order
to try and address it
from a new, truly from a new perspective.
It occurred to me as we
were discussing this,
however that some people, and yes,
maybe I'm talking a little
bit about my own experience.
We have a sense of our own identity
and how people view us and
our ability to be functional
in the world in ways that we like,
effective at work or a good brother
or a good mother or father,
human being in the world.
We have relationships.
And I think that one
thing that I have heard,
and maybe I've experienced
is that sometimes those
maladaptive thoughts or behaviors,
the things that generate a kind
of a repetition of anger
or of arousal or activation
or sadness, that we have
some internal process
where we funnel that into a
functionality in the world.
So we I'll give a more concrete example.
So in thinking about things
that have upset me in the past
and in imagining bad
outcomes in the future,
there's a certain
internal state of arousal
that comes about.
And for many years, I
was able to use that,
not to feel angry,
but rather to work an
extra three hours a day
- [Paul] Right.
- Or to pack my schedule with
work and social engagement.
So I could show up in a way that I,
hopefully was a very good brother
to my sister for instance.
- [Paul] Right.
- So in a way it was a,
it was a transformation
of something negative
inside of me.
- [Paul] Yes.
- Into a functionality in the world
that was actually very
rewarding and beneficial.
- [Paul] Yes.
- And yet in describing it,
I can immediately see how it
would be wonderful if I could
source from something else.
- [Paul] Hm- hm.
- And yet I, you can imagine,
and I can imagine how
one would be reluctant,
maybe even terrified of
giving up that source.
- Yes.
- [ Andrew] It's a fuel.
and I think in knowing some
of the traumas of other people
and their reluctance
to work through those,
obviously I'm not a therapist,
I sense this over and over again,
that one's positive identity
can often be linked to something
difficult in their past.
- [Paul] Yes.
- And so people are reluctant
to give up this fuel.
- [Paul] Yes.
- Because it it's in that
sense, it's functional.
The only thing that allowed
me to kind of start to address
this and why I'm still
so curious about this,
'cause I don't think I've worked
through this process completely,
again, a little more
self-disclosure there,
is that I was told that these words,
just imagine how much better it would be
if you could source from a different fuel,
a fuel that felt better.
- Right.
- Maybe it was on the, it was on this,
this sentence.
It was, maybe you could actually be
much more effective.
- [Paul] Yes.
- Maybe you could be 10
times the better brother.
- [Paul] Yes.
- Maybe you could have 10 times
more insight or work capacity, etcetera.
So it's on that hint of a promise that I,
at least I was inspired to
start looking into these things
and reading about trauma
in your book and elsewhere,
and start to think about this.
So again, I realize this
is a long winded question
and a somewhat complex idea, but I think,
or I hope that people will
be able to resonate with this
idea that sometimes we
want to stay attached
to this short term soothing
that the punishment
distraction or control
because it evokes this arousal
and then we can apply that arousal.
- Yes, yes.
I think what you're describing maps
I think clinically to what
gets called sublimation.
So there's something
negative inside of us,
but we sort of transfer that energy,
we transfer that into something
that is adaptive or
that is positive, right?
So the idea of the anger, right?
When I think of that thing
and it makes anger in me,
I channel that into harder work, right?
Or I channel that into like,
I'm going to go be nicer
to my brothers, some right,
something like that.
And there's validity to that, right?
But it can become like self
justifying if a person thinks,
well, look at what this
is doing for me, right?
I wouldn't work as hard without it.
Right now we start to become
attached to the trauma.
Whereas I think what you
had said is absolutely true
that just because we can sublimate
some of the negative
affect, feeling, emotion
that comes from trauma into something
productive doesn't mean
that that's best, right?
I mean we can get to our destination
by taking a very circuitous route, right?
We might waste an hour getting
there, but we get there.
That doesn't mean that that's best.
And it also doesn't look
at all the negative, right?
In this example, the wasted
fuel, the wasted time, right?
We get somewhere, but
we are not optimizing.
And I have yet to see one person
who has addressed the trauma
and become less functional, right?
It's always either,
they're just as functional,
but they're happier, right?
Or more functional
because as you said, like,
just because we may be
able to sublimate, well,
maybe what's going on will
be 10 times better, right?
If we weren't sublimating
because the sublimation limits us, right?
It limits our perspective
to only what we can see
and do through the lens of the trauma.
And that is never better
than the alternative.
- Thank you for that.
- Yeah, you're welcome, yeah.
- Let's discuss how one could
or should go about finding
a really good therapist.
Typically in my experience,
this is done by word of mouth.
There's this person you
might want to work with them
and they're really great,
but what are some of the characteristics
that one should look for?
And should we take into account whether
or not we are a person who for instance,
I've heard this from listeners,
although I'm clearly,
I'm definitely not talking about myself
here in cloaking something.
Some people will say,
I want to work with a somatic
therapist because I've actually
heard someone say, I think in fields,
I feel stuff in my body.
So I want to work with someone
who can really acknowledge that
or someone else will say,
I want to work with somebody
who has this orientation
or that orientation or is open
to my particular lifestyle,
or isn't going to tell me that
I have to leave my relationship.
I feel like people already
show up to the question
of who to work with with
all these, you know,
things internally,
some of which are voiced
and some of which aren't.
So I'd love for you to talk
about maybe some of the,
the core features of a
really good therapist
and then how to look for a therapist.
And also how to think about oneself
in looking for a therapist.
- [Paul] Right.
- Because of these kind
of predispositions.
- [Paul] Right, right.
Well, there's a lot of data about this
over the years,
if you look at what are the top 10
important factors to find in a therapist,
just repeat rapport 10 times, right?
I mean, that's the key.
And if you think about that,
it's pretty amazing, right?
Because therapeutic modalities
can be so different, right?
And I think what that's
telling us is, in a way,
something very obvious, right?
Like what does rapport mean?
Like, you know, it's somebody
that's paying attention, right?
It's trust, it's a back and forth.
It's like, yeah. even though
I'm doing something difficult,
I'm doing it with someone
who's really helping me,
someone who's in it with me, right?
Someone who's really paying attention.
Wants me to be better.
That's indispensable, I mean,
it's just indispensable.
And I write in the book is someone,
a therapist not making eye contact
or this is the way they do it, right?
And you know,
you got to fit into the
box of the way they do it.
That is not going to be helpful.
And then what I,
what I think about that is
the different modalities.
It doesn't actually tell us that,
oh, the modalities are irrelevant.
I think that's not true.
I think that good therapists
are not pigeonholed
by a certain modality.
They may come at the world largely
through a psychodynamic
or a CBT or a DBT lens.
There's lots of different,
ways to do therapy.
But when you really talk to those people,
really good experience therapists,
it's all coming through
the vehicle of the rapport,
but they're practically shifting
to what the person needs.
I don't understand the idea that like, oh,
I just do this, right?
I don't do that.
And when people are pigeonholed that way,
I don't think they help their
patients very well, right?
We have to be diverse enough to say, hey,
I want all the arrows
in the quiver, right?
And even though there might
be one that I favor and that's
the lens I see things through,
no, I can be versatile, I can shift,
I can adapt to what this person needs.
And I think if you have
that, you've got to,
if you have that, you've
got a winning combination.
- Great, so people should
perhaps try a few therapists
and maybe have a session or
two or three to see if they,
the rapport feels like it's taking root.
Is that?
- [Paul] Yeah.
- Do you have that right?
- Yeah, and I think that's why word
of mouth is important, right?
If someone you trust tells you,
hey, this is a good person
that says a lot, right?
It already makes the pretest probability,
is quite high.
But yes, it's interesting to see
when like people have a therapist
or they called their insurance
and they're assigned a therapist.
This thought that like, oh,
that's the person I have to have now.
And it's like, no, you should look at that
like anyone you'd be interviewing, right,
for a job, right?
But you got to bring again,
the right set of thoughts
to that to be helped, right?
Which is that I want someone
who has rapport with me.
I don't want someone who's
going to make it easy, right?
Who's like, well, it's,
gosh, it's kind of pleasant,
because then that means
they're not talking
about the difficult things, right?
So if one brings, like, I know
this isn't going to be easy.
I got to talk about
difficult things, right?
Even if one doesn't recognize
or I got to talk about
the trauma in me, right?
But to go to therapy
thinking, no, it's, I mean,
sometimes it's enjoyable,
but a lot of times, right,
it's not, right?
It's hard work.
It can be excruciating.
We can cry during it, but to say,
right, that that's how
I'm going to be helped.
And I want someone who's
going to do that with me,
who's really looking at,
what's going on inside of me,
how do we help me?
And I can feel sort of
the robustness of that.
If one brings that approach
and then looks at the therapist
through that lens,
you're very likely to
then move on from someone
who's not a good choice, right?
And really stick with someone who is,
even though that doesn't mean
it's always like pleasant
and enjoyable.
I mean, it has to not be that sometimes.
- Right.
Maybe we could drill a little deeper
into the mechanics of therapy.
I put out a few questions to
audience asking what they want
to know about therapy and it was amazing.
I got hundreds, if not
thousands of responses saying,
how should I show up to therapy?
So for instance,
should people take a five minute
meditative drop in before?
Or should they just show
up cold and let it emerge.
During therapy,
is it a good idea to take notes
or to not take notes
and then post therapy,
how should clients,
patients as they're sometimes
called, one or the other,
I never know which,
how should they process that information?
Should they take some
designated time afterwards
and in an ideal world,
take a 30 minute walk
afterwards and think about
the material or should they set it aside
and come back to it?
Of course there are constraints,
work and family, etcetera.
But you know we,
there's a lot of knowledge out
there about how to best show
up to a workout, warm
up for five, 10 minutes,
then do this, etcetera
and then the cool down.
I mean, here, we're talking
about hard psychological work
aimed at bettering oneself.
So to my knowledge,
I've not ever seen this
information anywhere.
It'd be very useful to hear,
hear your thoughts on this.
- Yeah.
Well, I'm not trying to duck the question,
but I think it varies so much by person.
So if you think about the
first part of your question,
I think was how to show
up to therapy, right?
And I think the answer would be whatever
lets you be fully present
when you're in therapy.
Now for some people that's
going to be, I show up early,
I say it, I call myself,
I meditate a little bit.
I mean, that's how then
they're present, right?
For other people, you know,
they just, they show up,
walk into the room, they can
stop another present, right?
So it's whatever works for that person.
So that they're really
there, their thoughts,
their energy is really in what's going on.
And the same thing
applies on the other end.
There are people who are
really well served by,
going for a walk if they can,
or sitting quietly after therapy,
kind of putting that in order, right?
Otherwise they lose some of it, right?
Or like some of the ahas, right?
Or the, oh, that's an interesting thought
that they really need to put it in order.
Maybe that involves taking some
notes during therapy, right?
For other people, they need
to do the exact opposite.
They need to like leave,
not think about that at all.
And then they can reflect on
it later and learn from it.
So we're so different.
Human beings, there's
such a diversity in us
that there's no hard answer to that,
but it's like being present
when it's happening,
then being able to sort of consolidate
and retain what's been
gained is most important.
And I think we have to figure
that out person by person.
I mean, I try and do
that in the work of like
what's serving this person best.
And sometimes we,
sometimes it evolves and
sometimes we talk about it,
but it varies so much.
- Hmm.
- If someone were thinking about embarking
on therapy or more therapy
to address trauma or just
general issues of life,
what is the frequency that you recommend?
I could imagine two extreme models.
One is, okay,
I'm going to finally tackle this trauma.
I'm going to do therapy
three times a week,
but for a shorter period
of time, six months,
over and out versus this open
ended model of once a week,
typically for as long as it takes.
- Right, right.
I think that also varies.
And I work with people
in varied ways from oh,
someone who's doing well
and like we meet for a half
hour every six months, right?
To doing week long,
hourly sessions, to
spending three intense days
with someone in a row, right?
So I think as far as like
kind of guiding principles,
what I have found in my own life,
'cause I value my own
therapy tremendously.
So I found in my own life
and in my own clinical work
that if it's less than once a week,
then it's hard for us to retain really.
We spend a lot of time
kind of catching up, okay,
what's happened?
Let's get back to the place
we were at before, right?
Which is why I think if we're
really going to get somewhere,
we're not just trying to
maintain something, right?
Then I think once a week for an hour
is really kind of the minimum, right?
But more intensive work.
It's like the more I intense it is,
it's not linear, right?
It's an exponential gain.
Like we do a lot of intensive work, right?
where someone will come
and do 30 clinical hours
with us over the course of a week.
So five or six different
clinicians, 30 clinical hours.
And you know,
we've found that the benefits
of doing that are immense.
It's like let's say a year's worth
of therapy consolidated and
you take well, 30 hours,
let's say, we go almost every week,
maybe that's 45 or 50 hours,
but 30 hours with that kind of intensity
is worth probably 60 hours,
done in a different way,
because then it's in us
in an active way, right?
It's in the therapist in an active way,
it becomes very, very dynamic.
So I think turning up the intensity,
if there's something that
we really need to process,
absolutely makes sense.
And I do that in my own life
is something now's
like, whoa, it's really,
somebody is really distressing me
and it's linking into prior trauma
and I can see what's going on in me.
Now I start to have
ruminative thoughts, you know,
with negativity, I'm like,
I got to go more, right?
Because I got to do that processing.
So I can get to the place that I am,
which is not that,
it's not that the trauma
has no impact on me, right?
It' that the impact is much
less than it was before
the therapy and that I most often
and more often than not
have an ability to see
when it's now intruding into my thoughts.
And it's taking me away from like
what I really think and believe,
or being able to draw
logic and emotion together
and make good decisions.
Turning up the intensity
then absolutely makes sense.
- This very deep, intensive
work of 30 hours in a week.
What brings somebody to some,
the type of work of that sort?
Is it a suicide risk or a
severe addiction situation?
I mean, how does one
gauge how much therapy
they ought to be doing
and should it always be
on the therapist to decide that frequency?
What would bring someone
to a situation of five
therapists in 30 hours
a week in one week?
- Right, right.
Yeah, it's usually a person
who is really distressed
by something whether that's,
it's so negatively impacting their life
or sometimes a person
comes to realization.
I just can't take this anymore, right?
I'm sick of the cyclical depression.
I got to stop having panic attacks.
I need help, right?
But it's usually some,
crisis point with the idea
of crisis in the meaning of,
okay, something comes
to a head and after it,
things are going to be different, right?
Not a crisis and things are
going to be negative afterwards,
but a point where, where then
that cognitive flexibility
comes to the fore of like,
well, I need to do
something different, right?
So that's often what brings us.
Sometimes it's other
people pointing it out
or somebody's had an
intervention somewhere or yes,
that person's been hospitalized
after a suicide attempt
or they've gone back to
rehab again for the third or fourth time.
And their life is really in danger.
Sometimes it's that.
And sometimes it's a person
realizing, yeah, I just want to,
I want to look at myself, I want
to understand myself better.
I know that what's going on in me,
isn't as good as it can be, right?
So I think people can come to it
for all sorts of different ways.
And I think, yes,
I think a lot of times it
would be the therapist to say,
more work, more intensive
work or can make a difference.
But I think the person also needs to,
take ownership, right?
Of their own therapy and say,
if I don't feel helped enough,
well, I have to think about that, right?
And talk to the therapist
about that, 'cause it,
maybe that therapist isn't a match, right?
Or maybe you talk to the
therapist and the therapist
can change his or her approach, right?
Or maybe you talk to the therapist
and increase the frequency, right?
But the idea is to be aware of it, right?
And if one's needs,
aren't being met to
acknowledge that, right?
'Cause people can get
into a rhythm of therapy
where it's really not helping them, right?
But they either feel sort
of nihilistic about it.
Like, oh, I'm no better and
I'm going to therapy, right?
Or sometimes there's a sense
that while I'm in therapy,
so I'm kind of checking
that box of doing something
for myself, but it's not
really getting me anywhere.
And then the part of the
brain that's controlled
by the guilt and shame and avoidance
thinks that's a great idea, right?
So again, this ability
to observe ourselves
and like what's going on,
am I being helped in the way,
do I feel helped, right?
Am I in some ways,
even like happy that
I'm not feeling helped.
'Cause I don't have to face
this thing I don't want to face, right?
Or am I too afraid to say
I need more help, right?
Do we really need to look at ourselves?
And this is where the insurance systems
often are very difficult,
'cause it's hard sometimes
for a person to say,
I need more therapy 'cause that
may not be possible, right?
So there are sort of negative factors
in the world around us.
But ultimately I think the
answer to the question comes down
to observing ourselves
and taking ownership
of like what's going on in
us and how we're feeling.
And then feeling that,
that commitment to self
or to self-care to say,
I need to go change this.
- And for those that
maybe don't have the means
or insurance or access to do even one day
a week therapy in the journaling model.
- [Paul] Yes.
- Could one perhaps take an entire day
as awful as it might seem,
to do a lot of journaling
and thinking and walking,
do a self-generated intensive.
Do you think there's utility to that?
- I mean there could be,
but again it depends by person 'cause
there could also be
something negative about that
if it's someone who's not at the point,
not ready for that, right?
I mean we don't come at,
we don't come directly at
the trauma immediately,
at least most of the time
we don't do that, right?
And we often don't explore it in depth.
Like this idea that, oh,
that person now has to go through
every second of the trauma
is actually not true.
I mean sometimes it is, but that's,
that's not the common situation, right?
So more often that
person has to acknowledge
like the example of like
I was sexually abused
and have to acknowledge
that and to, and say,
okay, like, gosh,
what has that done to me?
That doesn't mean,
well let's parse out every moment
of like how that was and
the terror of that, right?
So that can lead people
to a worse place, right?
So, I think the idea of
biting off small pieces,
so to speak where a
person is writing, right?
Or is talking.
But I think if one is writing,
it is good to communicate
with another, right?
Another trusted person.
And if there's not someone
in one's personal life,
there are clergy members,
even if one isn't a affiliated
with an organized religion,
you could probably go places
and get clergy to want to help you, right?
I mean, there are people out there
who want to help other people.
So we say, what if someone
has no one, I mean,
almost never do we have
no one here, right?
'Cause we could probably go find someone,
but we need to kind of
take that in pieces.
So there's some risk like trying
to do the intensive thing,
you know, on one's own.
And that's where I would put in,
if a person's having suicidal thoughts
or even thoughts of death,
of not wanting to be alive,
I don't deserve to be alive.
I mean, these are warning
signs for really getting help.
So there are some signs that say, hey,
don't try and do that on your own, right?
Go try and find a resource.
And it's things that get to
that level of severity of,
and often a person knows that.
I mean, am I in a place where I know
I'm not healthy
and I'm having kind of scary thoughts,
then we need,
that's a person who
really shouldn't be doing
that on their own.
- Great, thank you for that.
- Yeah, you're welcome.
- So we've been talking
a lot about talking.
- Huhm.
- And now I'd like to talk a
little bit about chemistry.
- Yes.
- Drugs.
- [Paul] Yes.
- So maybe first we could
talk prescription drugs.
I mean you're a psychiatrist,
so you're approved to,
and presumably do prescribe
medication where appropriate.
I mean, this is a vast
landscape of course.
We've got ADHD and I should just tell you,
I get more questions about
ADHD and the drugs related
to ADHD and dopamine than any
other topic, any other topic.
So there's ADHD, there's
OCD, there's depression,
there's antidepressants and so forth.
Is there some way that we can,
wrap our arms around all of that
as a way of waiting into this,
this drug question and just address,
how does one decide when
medication is useful?
Because in the end,
the dissection tool that the psychiatrist
or therapist has is language.
And at some point,
one has to make an assessment
about dopamine or serotonin
or whether or not a given drug would help.
And most therapies,
I believe don't involve putting
someone in a brain scanner.
And to my knowledge,
there still is not a very
good blood test to assess,
oh, is this person's dopamine low or high,
correct me if I'm wrong.
And ultimately that,
and I know there are companies out there,
so I'm not trying to
undermine those companies.
But if I happen to do
that in this statement,
if you take a blood test
and find that your serotonin
metabolites are low,
my understanding is it's
possible that you are too low
in serotonin in the brain,
but that's a very indirect window
into what's really going on.
So how does,
how do you think about
prescription drugs in the context
of treating trauma and other
conditions and then maybe
we'll drill into some of the
more specific conditions?
- Sure, I mean,
I would first comment that
right there aren't tests
for these things.
And I think the tests for metabolites,
I mean, things are so different.
By the time, what we're talking
about has been metabolized,
often to some very significant extent.
Left the brain,
now it's in the peripheral blood
that we really don't
learn from that, right?
I think that we tend to over
utilize medicines in this
country because we have
a healthcare system
that often that's so based
on throughput that we want to
polish the hood when there's a
problem in the engine, right?
So we overutilize medicines
often as an end point, right?
Oh, we're going to make that
person's depression better
with an antidepressant.
Well, I mean maybe, right?
But most of the time for
the person's depression
to really get better and stay better,
they need to unravel what's
driving the depression, right'
So the first step is I think
they're cut two steps to it, right?
The first assessment step is,
is there a diagnosis that,
that the vast majority of the time,
if not sometimes, all the time,
really warrants a medicine?
So the bipolar disorder, OCD, ADD, right?
These are diagnoses that we,
we understand more about
them and what's going on
in the brain and how medicines
can treat or stabilize them,
which doesn't mean the
medicine is necessarily,
it's not a substitute for therapy, right?
But sometimes the medicine and
therapy can go hand in hand.
So for OCD, for example,
warrants therapy, but it almost,
not always, but it almost
always warrants medicine too,
so that you can ease the
systems that are making
the rigidity and the
repetition in the brain.
So the first kind of branch point can be,
what is the diagnosis?
What is the level of severity, right?
And I think that's very,
very important where I
think it's a little more,
maybe even interesting is using medicines
to help the person engage in the therapy
as productively as possible.
And here's where I think we're so limited
by how we categorize medicines
and this sort of pharmaceutical
insurance driven medical system
we have that I think throws
us off in tremendous ways.
So you think about how
medicines are categorized,
so antidepressants.
And the vast majority of people who are
helped by antidepressants,
they're not, they don't have
clinically severe depression, right?
Those medicines create more
distress tolerance in us, right?
And if you think about
how helpful that can be,
if you're going to go,
now you're going to do
something difficult, right?
You're going to bring that
trauma or the stressors
to the surface and you're going to process
and you're going to try
and make life change.
If we can make more
distress tolerance in us,
that can be so, so much better, right?
And think about the category
of medicines that are called
antipsychotics, which really
puts people off, right?
But most of the prescriptions
for antipsychotics
are not for psychosis, right?
And there are ways in which
low dosing of some of those
medicines can help intervene
in negative pathways, right?
In pathways that are about distress.
And sending out those tendrils
of neurons that are about hyper vigilance
and avoidance, right?
In in our brain.
And we can often get at that.
And if you can improve
someone's distress tolerance
and you can use medicines
that take away what clinically
is rumination, right?
Not the standard meaning of that word,
but the clinical meaning of it,
where there are distress
centers in our brain
that are overactive.
And then we get stuck in these
maladaptive negative pathways
where we think about something
over and over and over again,
with no real chance of solving
it because that's not what's
going on inside of us.
So medicines can help that,
but we have to have some flexibility
around their conception
and the modern medical system
of like 15 minute visits,
to a psychiatrist that are weeks apart.
I mean, I don't understand
how that goes well, right?
In the vast majority of times,
I think it doesn't go well
because it's not enough time
to do the therapy, even
generate the understanding.
So then medicines get
thrown into the person.
This is how,
we use, I think approximately
five times as much medicine,
I think across the board as say
the Dutch population, right?
Then you think, well,
why is five times more,
is a lot more medicine, right?
And you know, they have
a healthcare system
and a cultural system that to
the best of my understanding
is more rooted in taking
responsibility for oneself, right?
So if a person comes in and
cholesterol is high, right?
The first order of business is,
hey, you could take better
care of yourself, right?
Like this person really needs to lose
some weight exercise more, right'
They're not just jumping to like,
let me give you a medicine and you know,
and shift you through
the healthcare system
and out the other side of the door, right?
And the same thing is
true in mental health,
and I'm not trying to be critical
to the psychiatrists or the
nurse practitioners or people
who are practicing in that way,
because oftentimes there
is no choice, right?
If they're working in a
healthcare system that,
that the standard is highly
spaced or spaced apart,
15 minute visits, what
alternative is there, right.
But to look at, okay,
I'm going to use medicines
because I don't have another
tool to bring to bear.
So I think the healthcare system
and its focus on throughput
and it's short term talk about,
we talk about short term response, right?
Short term soothing at the
expense of long-term health.
And I think that is the metaphor for,
that applies to our
healthcare system, right?
Where if we,
if we are going to try and
treat a symptom in a short term,
we're going to do it in a 15 minute visit,
that we're going to do it in a way
that maybe it soothes a symptom,
maybe it doesn't, but it
does not get at the problem.
We need to invest more
resources to get at the problem
and I think that's
where a sort of protest,
if people, as a society, we say,
look, we don't like the way
our healthcare is going.
Like, we need more focus
on what the actual problems
are that yes,
we would spend more money,
to treating people and
taking care of people
'cause it's more human time,
but ultimately about less
suffering, less death, right?
And ultimately more productivity.
I think as an economy,
we would save so much money
if we spend money on the human
aspects of mental healthcare,
because people would be more functional.
They're spending less time
in the hospital, right?
They're more productive
when they're working.
There's less entry into the
criminal justice system.
So I think medicines get overused
in part for systemic reasons,
in large part, for systemic reasons.
And also for some of these
categorization reasons,
oh, that person meets
some technical criteria
for depression.
We got to give them this medicine
instead of really thinking,
wait, what's going on in this person.
And I see this over and over again.
I see one who is on seven medicines
and they're on seven medicines
to treat seven different symptoms.
And now they have side effects
from all those seven medicines.
Maybe two of them are to
treat the side effects
from the other five, right?
And that's bad, right?
And if you really get at
what's going on in them,
now they're doing much better
and maybe they're on two medicines, right?
So I dunno if that's a
helpful answer to that.
- It is, it's a very helpful answer.
I mean, I think at least in the spheres
that I run these days,
I hear a lot of negative
statements about antidepressants.
I think, I'm old enough to remember
the book, "Listening to Prozac."
I remember when Prozac and its
and things like it
first started showing up
and the excitement.
And then nowadays I hear more
about the problems with all
these drugs and maybe that's just,
'cause I have arms in
the, both the scientific,
but also in the kind of wellness community
where people think a lot
about behavioral change.
Fortunately I think
that's that they do that.
But of course these
drugs, as you mentioned,
can have enormous utility as well.
- [Paul] Yes.
- I'd like to just pick up on one theme
that I haven't heard a
lot about anywhere else,
which is the short term versus
the long term use of these drugs.
'Cause I could imagine,
someone feeling like they're
finally going to tackle something
that's been inside them
for a long time either
because they're really struggling
or because they're just done with
not working it through
and they decide to start a medication
that would give them higher
levels of distress tolerance
for a short while.
I mean, is there anything to say
that someone couldn't take a
properly prescribed medication
for a week or for the first
three months of the work?
- Yes.
- And then know that they can come off it
because I think that the black
and white model of, okay,
you're either going to start
this drug and stay on it forever
or be taking some drugs forever.
- [Paul] Right.
- Or you're not going to take anything.
I mean, that just seems to,
life doesn't have,
does life have to work that way?
- [Paul] Right.
Is there a short term use
that can be effective?
- Yeah, absolutely, yes.
In American medicine we are
so much better at starting
medicines than we are at
taking them away, right?
And part of that I think
is driven by such a strong
presence of the pharmaceutical industry
and the pharmaceutical industry
does a lot of very good things, right?
But you know,
there's such thing as too
much of a good thing, right?
And then as a society, when
something seems positive,
this I think also is human nature.
We can overinvest in it, right?
So you think about when Prozac
and those kinds of medicines
came out, they were safer medicines,
they're billed as antidepressants
and the thought was,
well, they're going to
fix depression, right?
And it's not how that works, right?
So if we look at them as tools, right,
then we can deploy them
sometimes for the longer term
'cause sometimes that's necessary.
But absolutely for the
shorter term, absolutely.
If we thought of Prozac and
those kind of medicines,
not as, oh they're
antidepressants, we think, look,
what they do is they,
they seem to make there be
more serotonin in certain
circuits that are important
for mood regulation,
anxiety regulation, distress tolerance.
So those medicines can
really help somebody
if they're very severely depressed
and we want to sort of
get them feeling better.
They can also help someone if
they could use more distress
tolerance in a discrete
period of time, right?
When we think about them that way,
we think about them as
tools that we could apply
for short term or long term.
We don't see them as fixes, right?
And we don't see them as then substitutes
for the human to human work
that needs to be done.
I mean, I've been sort of in my training
at times in healthcare systems
and I've seen in many other circumstances
that look at medicines as
answers and this idea that,
that person is a, and a lot of times
there'll be a number, right, right?
And the number is the diagnosis
and that number gets this medicine.
And I'm not sure we could
be more misguided than that
and that's what leads to adding
medicines, adding medicines,
it's not working.
Of course it's not working,
because no one's really paying
attention to what's going on.
So add more medicines and then
medicines for the medicines.
And I mean, we know this is true.
We know this is true,
but we haven't had the
wherewithal as a society
to say like with a lot
of things in society,
to say like this isn't okay, right?
I mean, we need more.
Like give these people
who are trying to help us.
They need more latitude to help us.
We need more human to human contact
to get at what's really going on, and yes,
that's an investment of
time and energy and money
in the short term and
sometimes that's money
from the systems, right?
But if we do that, my
goodness, look at the,
look at the payoff of that.
- What is your thought about anxiety
and ADHD as a separate phenomena,
in terms of medication.
Again, ADHD is the thing
that seems to come up most in questions.
I can't tell you the number
of especially students,
but also young working professionals
and even people who are
outside those categories
who are interested or taking
Ritalin, Adderall, Modafinil
or Armodafinil or Vyvanse,
because they seem to
struggle focusing without it.
Or, and I don't know,
'cause I'm not one of those individuals,
or because they seem to just
like how well they can focus
when they do take those compounds.
And so my understanding is
these compounds mainly increase
dopaminergic transmission in the brain,
also adrenaline, epinephrine in the brain.
So they're more or less stimulants.
They look a lot like, at least chemically,
they look a lot like
cocaine and amphetamine,
although they're not quite
cocaine and amphetamine.
So should we be concerned about this?
Is this a different sort of epidemic?
Can these drugs be used to train the brain
to focus and then people can
withdraw from these drugs?
I mean, I think this is a huge topic
and one that maybe warrants
its own episode entirely,
but as long as we're on the topic,
what are your thoughts
about medication for ADHD?
- Sure, I think medication for ADHD
can be extremely effective
and the studies show us that, right?
They show us that if there is ADD,
then medication for ADD,
is very, very helpful and
that's true in youths,
it seems to be true if adults
have adult ADHD or ADD,
we kind of know that's true,
but all attention deficit
is not Attention Deficit Disorder, right?
And there we go to the
reflexive 15 minute visits,
throw medicines at things, right?
Attention deficit can come
from many, many places.
And one of them is anxiety, right?
There's so many other reasons
depression affects attention,
poor sleep affects attention,
poor diet can affect attention,
stress in life can affect attention.
So, and, and certainly trauma.
And the thing,
the problems that trauma spins
off can affect attention.
So this is really the,
this is really the truth that
while teaching once about
medicines and pharmacology,
I was frustrated about how
the answer to everything
was like, what medicine do we use?
What medicine do we
use, as opposed to like,
this is just one piece of the puzzle.
And I told an anecdote, which,
I think it was a clinical anecdote,
like what do you think is going on?
And I think that if I
told that to, I dunno,
middle school students or something,
they would probably say,
you just told a story of a
person with a rock in their shoe,
which is what I, the story
that I was actually telling, right?
But several people I was talking to,
they're physicians, right?
ADD, right?
It's like, no,
every time the person
steps down the rock hurts
and they're not able to
maintain attention, right?
Like that's what's going on.
But we're so programmed
to think about medicines
and inappropriate use of
ADD medicines, as you said,
there's dopaminergic impact.
There's epinephrine,
norepinephrine impact.
We're affecting what are called
prefrontal alpha 2 receptors
that like really need to be
helped if there's real ADD
but if there isn't, that
is not a good thing to do,
which is why it is quite fascinating
that when people have ADD,
they tolerate generally
stimulants very well,
without the other problems
that can come of stimulants.
And again, I don't know, I
don't claim to know why that is,
but we see that phenomenon.
But when people are being treated for ADD
and they don't have ADD,
which sometimes they
know they don't have ADD,
but the stimulants make
them function better.
So they go to somebody
and get the stimulants.
That's not a good thing to do, right?
'Cause stimulants, when
they're not needed over time,
they do affect our physical function.
They affect our judgment, right?
There are a lot of negative
things that come from that.
They can affect the
vigilance inside of us.
So, yes, it's a valid diagnosis,
but it gets made when it's
not present very often,
which we see with a lot of diagnoses
that you can throw medicine at.
We see the same thing
with bipolar disorder.
True bipolar disorder
is extremely important
to utilize medicines effectively,
but how many people are
diagnosed with bipolar disorder
who have, they absolutely
don't have bipolar disorder,
but it can be a catchall diagnosis
because there is in a sense,
"something to do for it," right?
And you can throw medicine at it, right?
So I mean, what do we expect, right?
If we have a healthcare
system where you get 15 minute
visits with your psychiatrist,
of course we're going to
throw medicines at everything.
And then the training paradigms
are going to look at it through that lens.
And then very often again,
I give the example of seeing
somebody on seven medicines.
I mean the first thought I
have is how many of those
medicines are actually counterproductive?
And a lot of the time it's not like, oh,
every now and then one
is counterproductive.
No, that's the case.
That's the case a lot of the time.
And again, I come back to,
if we're not putting thought into it,
what other result would we expect?
- Thank you for that answer.
I'm very curious what
constitutes negative effects
of stimulants.
So if somebody's taking
Adderall or Ritalin in order
to work longer hours or focus
because they have attention deficit,
but not necessarily ADHD.
And again, I'm not
recommending anyone do this.
I've just heard the numbers
that have come back at least
from surveys and discussions
with colleagues at Stanford and elsewhere,
other college campuses that
upwards of 75% of college
students use semi
regularly, these drugs off,
not by prescription, just
to study and to learn.
- [Paul] Yes.
- I can imagine sleep
issues because people,
because these are stimulants,
what sorts of other issues
can they create for people
problems that they can create?
- Sure, I mean,
I think a touchstone maybe
that's running through
our conversation, right,
is prioritizing the short term benefit
over solving a long-term problem, right?
Which we might say is a human tendency
and we see it across the
topics that we're discussing.
So, short-term use of stimulants.
Sure, people are more alert.
They can stay awake more,
they can study more intensely and longer.
Okay, there's some
short-term benefit of that,
over there, even there,
there can be problems, right?
But we can say,
let's just say for sake of
argument that in the short term,
there's something to be
gained by doing that, right?
But oh my goodness,
there's so much that is,
there's so much risk to that, right?
And how many times have I seen someone
who they're doing that
and they're just doing
that to study, right?
And now they're addicted
to the amphetamines
and their behavior changes
and they don't know it.
Talk about shifting our brain
towards a more defensive,
sort of suspicious, outward look,
view of the world that
we see a lot of that.
So we see judgment impairment,
we see heightened levels of anxiety.
We see more impulsivity
in decision-making.
And sometimes we,
it can get to the point
of seeing Frank psychosis.
Now, that's not common,
but have I seen young people
who've done exactly what
you're describing, right?
They're using Adderall or
they're using Ritalin to study.
And then I see them when they're
coming into the hospital,
they're screaming about how
someone's trying to hurt them.
Boy, it's the worst case scenario,
but it shows like that's
where that can go.
And how much is there between the,
oh, I'm just using it to
study and that severe,
outcome that is actually
quite negative for a person
and it might change how they think
about that friendship or
that relationship, right?
A lot negative happens
when we change our brains
without an ability to see like,
what is it actually doing to us?
So, which is part of my whole
theme about trauma, right?
It changes our brains and
we don't know it, right?
Well the same can be,
the same is often true of
amphetamines used inappropriately.
It shifts our brain.
And we don't realize that we're
a little bit more impulsive
in our decision making, a
little bit less trusting.
These are significant negative things
that if we don't know it,
the person will just say, yeah,
oh, I'm just using it to study.
I'm using it to work more.
That's not, you know,
that's not without it's
high level of risk.
- What are your thoughts on cannabis?
I've said it many times on this podcast
before and I'll say again,
I feel fortunate that I've
never really been attracted
to alcohol or drugs of any kind ,
so much so that if all the
alcohol and all the marijuana
and all the cocaine
amphetamine disappeared,
I wouldn't notice any
change in my life, right?
And I feel lucky in that way,
'cause I know a lot of people feel
an attraction to these things
that it is almost a gravitational force.
- [Paul] Yes.
- From their first drink, they just feel,
I once heard it described in this,
I think it was an Augusten
Burroughs book, "Dry"
where he was an alcoholic.
He said that the first drink he had,
it felt like this magic elixir
that meshed with the
physiology of his blood
in the most seamless way
and as I was reading this, I thought,
oh my goodness, first of all,
that's the most foreign experience
for me in terms of alcohol.
And second gosh, that must be terrible.
And you can,
but at the same time you
could really understand
why someone would be drawn to that.
- Yes.
So cannabis nowadays is legal
or decriminalized in
many areas of the U.S.
A lot of people seem to use the argument,
it's better than drinking
or they only do it for
sleep or anxiety management.
I'm not looking to demonize
or support the cannabis.
So what are your thoughts about cannabis
for anxiety management, depression?
And maybe even for ADHD for that matter.
Sure.
- If I could make an
alcohol comment, right?
The number of times I've seen alcohol
like having been a good idea for coping
with something approaches zero, right?
Like the alcohol for
coping is just never good.
And there's an additional risk
factor that there's certain
genetic profiles where people
respond strongly to alcohol.
Like, as you're saying, it's not just,
oh, there's a little bit of
short term relief of distress,
but there's this sort of euphoric response
and those genetics,
we don't understand them completely.
They seem to be in Northern
European populations,
more prevalent as you head
west in Northern Europe.
So we understand where risk
factors are demographically,
but we can't pinpoint
that for any one person.
And there's a tremendous risk of that,
when a person responds so
strongly to alcohol or habituates
coping to alcohol.
Cannabis is a little bit
of a different story.
I mean, how I have seen that play out,
and again, this isn't
coming from any expertise
around the neuro the
neuropharmacology of it,
like how is this really
working in the brain?
But it comes from an observation
that what it seems to do is
to narrow our attentional
perspective, right?
So it's why people will
say, well, they want to,
they want to use cannabis
before like watching a movie with friends
or something, right?
And, and I think, okay,
I think why people are doing that
is because our cognitive spectrum narrows.
And then instead of worrying
about that thing at work
or that relationship issue,
one can just be present, right?
It gates out other
attentional intrusions, right?
So in some ways, I mean,
I've absolutely seen it
be helpful to people.
I mean, it's been legalized
in Oregon, which is where my,
I spent a lot of my time
and it's not where all of my practice is,
but what I have seen is
it is at times helpful,
safe around sleep, right?
Because a person can gate
out other intrusive thoughts
and they can just relax and go to sleep.
But there can be another side of that too,
that at higher levels of distress,
at higher levels of tension,
what it can do is narrow the focus
of cognition to the thing
that is negative, right?
So the idea that, oh, like,
oh, this is a treatment for,
depression, anxiety,
trauma, is not true, right?
Can it be helpful under
certain circumstances?
Like I think the answer to that is, yeah.
I mean, I know the answer to that is yes.
'Cause I've seen it play
out clinically that way,
but think it can also be harmful too.
So there, again, like
anything that has any power,
power to influence our brains,
we want to be thoughtful
and careful about it.
I mean, do I think that
it's safer than alcohol?
Yes, I mean, I mean, like we,
we so clearly see that.
Does that mean?
Or it's just uniformly safe?
No, right.
So we want to be respectful of anything
that can change how our brain is working
and I think that includes,
certainly includes alcohol.
And I think it certainly
includes cannabis too.
- I'd love to talk about
psychedelics for two reasons.
One, there seems to be a
tremendous amount of interest
in psychedelics as a
therapeutic clinical tool.
I know there's also recreational
use and I'll just preface
all this by saying that
my stance is we absolutely
know for sure that these
are controlled substances,
they're illegal to possess,
sell or use in most of the country.
There are few areas where
it, they are decriminalized.
- [Paul] Yes.
And psychedelics is a
broad category, of course.
And we can touch on some of
the different, different ones,
but whereas five years or so,
five years ago or so I
was truly afraid to say
the word psychedelics in
any kind of public venue,
there are laboratories at
Stanford working on ketamine,
psilocybin, MDMA, mostly in animal models.
There's terrific work going on
at Johns Hopkins University
School of Medicine,
Matthew Johnson's Lab,
and others looking at the
clinical applications,
mainly of high dose psilocybin and LSD.
There's the maps trials with MDMA.
- [Paul] Yes.
- So nowadays it's safe
for an academic like me
to say the word psychedelics.
And I'm, I'd love to
approach this question
of psychedelics from a place
of true exploration and curiosity.
But with the preface that
we're talking about this
in a legal clinical setting.
- [Paul] Yes.
- And the legality is something
that's now in process.
I don't think it's completed,
but that's my understanding,
but there are trials.
You can go to clinical
trials.gov and put in MDMA,
and you'll see a bunch of clinical trials
that are happening in
the recruiting subjects.
So I think it's safe to
have the conversation now,
and I'd love your thoughts
about psychedelics.
Maybe we could start
with psilocybin and LSD
as a broad category of drugs,
that at least my
understanding is they touch on
mainly the serotonin system,
some specific receptor
activation and modulation,
tend to change notions of space and time,
adjust internal state.
Maybe we would start there.
- [Paul] Yes.
- And then maybe venture
into some of the other ones.
So what are your thoughts on
these drugs for therapeutic
potential also potential
hazards, etcetera.
- Yeah, I think if we look
at the true psychedelics,
so psilocybin and LSD, right?
Because ketamine and MDMA,
they're different categories of medicine.
They're these sort of novel
tools to bring to bear.
But if we start with psilocybin,
LSD, true psychedelics,
I think why it is,
why they have gained so much momentum over
the last several years is
because the data coming
from the labs and the academic centers
is so powerfully positive.
And as someone who's,
I'm interested in anything
that's potentially helpful, right?
And I want to learn and understand that
because a lot of things that
are potentially helpful,
you know, you go and look at the data
and you see that that's not
helpful, that's harmful.
I think what we have
seen with psychedelics
is that they're so helpful, right?
And the trials are bearing that out.
And of course these are
used in professional hands
and with the right kind of guidance
are extremely powerful tools,
but used in the right way
by someone who knows how to utilize them
in the right setting can have
an immense positive impact.
And that's why I think
that the thought is there
across people and more and more
people feel comfortable saying
it and talking about it,
I mean we're in the state of Oregon now
where the thought is,
we're moving towards
legalization of psilocybin
early in 2023.
And it's part the new data, right?
And how it meshes with
the older data, right?
How it meshes with data
from the 60s and 70s
that showed such a strong, powerful impact
of these medicines.
And I have a whole set of
thoughts about what's happening
there and they're just
their conjectures, right?
But my read of, you know,
as best I can try and
understand the neuroscience
and the clinical applicability
and the changes is,
what happens is we see less communication
or less chatter in the outer
parts of the brain, right?
the the outer parts of the cortex.
And I think that as human beings,
we sort of glorify the parts
of the brain that only we have.
I mean, certainly in my growing up, right?
I mean, what did I learn?
Even if you think about like,
learning about the brain
in high school, right?
I learned that like, wow,
we're great as humans
'cause we have language
and other animals don't
and we can use tools and
like aren't we so great
because we have this part of
the brain that other animals
don't and it lets us function, right?
Okay, there's some truth to that.
That we can do things others can't do.
But we get lost often in the
outer parts of the cortex,
which I think are about survival, right?
So we come back to the things you
and I talked about early on of like,
why are these trauma
mechanisms in us, right?
So like so much of what's going on
in our brains is about survival.
And I think living so to
speak in the cortex, right?
And the outer part of the brain
is consistent with a focus on survival.
So if you think that's where language is,
that's where vision is,
that's where executive function is.
So planning and task execution,
so much of that is about making our way
in the world around us.
So we tend to glorify
that and think, well,
that's in a sense where
our existence is, right?
And I believe that is not true, right?
And again, can I say that for
sure, of course not, right?
But my read of 20 years
of doing clinical work
and thinking about all sorts of medicines
and thinking about the psychedelics
in a lot of depth,
I think that what they do is they take us
out of the cortex, right?
Because that's where we
run into these problems.
That's where we bounce
things over and over again
that the distress centers deepen our brain
and the brain stem kind of
align with the outer parts
of the cortex and they say, right,
we we're in distress.
We want to stay alive.
Often a lot of us have had
trauma that makes these changes
in the brain and then we're
thinking all the time,
like what would I do
if, if there were war,
what would I do if there's
civil war, if someone bombs us,
what will I do if the
economy collapses, right?
What will I do if somebody gets sick?
We're thinking all this future projection
that is all coming from
a place of fear, right?
It's all coming from a
desire to think about things
and control the future
with this part of the brain
that is so uniquely human, right?
And I think when we take
the neuro transmission
out of those places, right?
And we set it in a part of the brain
and say the insular cortex, right?
The parts of the brain
that are sort of in the middle, right?
Which I think, I believe is
where our humanness really is.
So the psychedelics make there
be less chatter communication
in these other parts of the brain.
And then we become seated
in the part of the brain
that I believe is most
about our experience
of true humanness,
which is why, when you read about,
people who have experiences
and I've heard about them
and people talk to me about this, right?
They've utilized it.
They talk with me.
So whether it's someone
telling me their story
or it's coming from research data,
it's why people can sort
of see with clarity that,
oh, that trauma, that thing
is not my fault, right?
Like we feel a sense of
compassion for ourselves.
We relieve ourselves,
release ourselves from guilt
and you say, why is this
so helpful to people?
And I think it's because it can do
what we are trying to
get at in good therapy,
but it can really catalyze
that by just putting a person
in that part of the brain that can see it
for what it is,
without all that chatter
in the cortex about,
hey, got to think it's your
father, you won't avoid it again
and that makes the repetition compulsion.
How do I think ahead to the
next thing that might happen
and what else bad might happen?
I mean, we don't get anywhere doing that.
And I think where we get somewhere
is when we seed ourselves
deeper in the brain,
which I think we do if,
if we're like doing really
good therapy and we're,
we're in the deep parts
of the brain, but these,
these psychedelics,
the medicinal value I believe
is putting us in that part
of the brain where a person
can really find truth.
And that's why I think that,
that's come so far in these few years
because I think that is
very clinically evident.
And I think we're going to
see more and more of the value
of that and how, what the
psychedelics do can become,
I believe a heuristic for
understanding like wait,
how are our brains really functioning?
And what are the parts that really matter
to our experience of being human?
It's those parts of the brain, right?
The deep parts of the
brain, the insular cortex
and the areas around it that
say light up when a person
has an experience of spiritual ecstasy
or an experience of connection
with another person, right?
We kind of have these telltale
markers that something
is going on there that's very
important and very special.
And I think we're more
attracted to the outer parts
of the brain in part 'cause
they're easier to study, right?
I mean, as you know, better than I do,
we started studying the brain
through lesion studies, right?
'Cause it was easy to,
or to see if a person got
hurt in this part of the brain
or had a stroke in that part
of the brain, what changes?
So we look at the cortex 'cause one,
it's easier to study and
we tend to glorify it.
And I think that has been misguided.
And I think that we're learning.
about how that's been misguided
through the study of these
novel modalities from
Western perspectives,
would of course they've
been used for a long,
long time in other cultures,
but novel from our perspective.
- Yeah, I'm fascinated by this idea
that in these middle brain structures is,
is where our humanity lies
and as you said,
I also wonder whether or not
other animals experience life
more from that orientation
with less chatter.
We can only guess, but.
- [Paul] right.
You know, that a dog lover
and being in the presence of
animals that seem to just be
present in what's happening in
their immediate environment,
not too much anticipation.
- Right, I mean, through sentient right?
I mean what you're talking about
is sentience, it's important.
And sentience is extremely
important, right?
And if we're going to
overvalue say language,
then I think we undervalue
sentience, right?
Which is why I think we tend
to undervalue animals, right?
And their suffering, we say,
well, they're not saying
anything about it, right?
And you know, they're not
writing about it, so, okay.
It's easy to ignore and we think about,
again the hubris of that right though,
because we can think and talk and write,
like we must be feeling more
than species that don't do that.
I mean I think,
I think that that is so true
and that we're going to
understand more about sentience
in other species and how,
that's at the core of existence.
And my hope would be that we value
more humans and animals, right?
Through the evolution
of that understanding.
- The hallucinations that
accompany psychedelics
like LSD and psilocybin have
such an attractive force
to them as a concept and as an experience.
And so I think most often when
people hear hallucinogens,
they think, and psychedelics,
they think about hallucinating.
- [Paul] Right.
- It makes sense why they would.
- But what's so interesting to
me is nothing in your answer
about psychedelics,
psilocybin and LSD focused
on hallucinations, per se.
It was more about feeling states,
accessing a feeling state or a relation
to an event or to a person or to oneself.
Maybe even I,
I caught hints of maybe
even empathy for one's self.
- Yes.
- [Andrew] For the first time.
- None of that had to
do with seeing sounds
or hearing colors and these kind of cliche
statements about hallucination.
So I am aware of laboratories,
one at a University of
California Davis in particular,
but a few others that are trying
to generate chemical variance
of psychedelics that lack the
hallucinogenic properties,
but maintain these other
properties as therapeutic tools.
And as I say that, I realize that I,
people in the psychedelic
community are probably thinking,
oh, that's horrible.
That's the dismantling of the core thing.
But the simple question is,
do you think the hallucinations
are valuable for anything?
- And I think we're really
getting into the philosophical,
right, the ontological, right?
There's this sort of trying
to understand being, right?
And I don't claim to
know the answer to that.
I think that at times it
seems like the hallucinations
have a metaphorical or a symbolic way
of being helpful, right?
Because people will come
to understand things
that they hold dear and true
after the experience, right?
That often, not always,
come through the lens
of the hallucinations.
So are the hallucinations necessary?
Are those hallucinations
sometimes important sometimes not?
I mean, I think we don't understand that.
And I think we want to be respectful
of the sort of mystery of that.
But what I think is fascinating
is when you think about
like substance abuse and
what that means is, well,
one aspect of that is that
a person has experiences,
thoughts, conceptions of self in the world
with the substance that
without the substance,
they know are wrong, right?
People talk about, you
know, liquid courage, right?
And okay, I feel better about myself
and I feel courageous 'cause
I've had a couple of drinks.
Now, when I, when I, after that,
I feel like normal about myself
and that was false, right?
And we see that like,
that's part of what substance
intoxication means, right?
But what we see with the
psychedelic medicines
is something that's
incredibly different, right?
That people are having
experiences that are so delinked
from our normal experience of reality.
And then when they come in a
sense back online with right,
in a normal cognitive way,
they realize like, wow,
now I'm applying all those mechanisms
of trying to understand truth and to that,
and what I see is that it's
true and wow, it's true.
Like, I mean, we hear that
all the time, which tells me,
hey, something different
is going on there.
And of course these are powerful tools
so misused like very
bad things can happen.
But you think about the clinical
utility and what does it
mean that so many people
change for the healthier
or even change their
lives after an experience
because it so resonates as like,
oh, now I understand
something that's true.
And it's not something bizarre.
It's like,
I wasn't responsible for
being raped that time
or I'm not less than even
though my sexuality or my gender
identity's different from some
silly binary concept, right?
Like people kind of often
get it and they feel
differently about themselves
and guilt and shame are impacted.
So I think we're likely to
see that they are powerful
anti-trauma mechanisms again,
used clinically in the right hands.
And I think that we're also going
to see that they're heuristic
for understanding our brain
that goes against what I see
as some of the reflexive hubris of,
well, the outer parts must be the best
because that's what makes
us human and other animals don't have it.
And we're better because we're human.
I mean, it makes no sense, you know?
- I'd like to talk about MDMA
and I'll preface this by saying
I was a participant actually,
technically I'm still a
participant in a clinical trial.
So I have experience of doing it twice
at the trial involves three
separate dosings of this.
I was reluctant to do it
outside of a clinical trial,
mostly because I was aware
there can be some cardiac effects.
And I liked the idea there
would be a clinician on hand.
And I'll just say that
I found the experiences
to be profound, beneficial
and very different
from one session to the next.
The first one felt
a whole collection
of ideas and relational
things came up that felt very
powerful and transformative.
And I do think that I learned there,
I exported a number of things,
my particular experience
isn't relevant here,
but the second time I expected
it to be the same way.
And it was very mellow and relaxing
and was deeply tied to kind
of notions of acceptance.
So there weren't all these
revelations and wow new insights.
It was very much about sort of grounding
into a kind of a calmer state.
So I have the personal experience
of benefiting from these in
ways that I think still benefit
me and was very struck
by the power of MDMA.
And my very crude understanding
of the pharmacology
and the state that is being under MDMA
is that it encourages or increases
dopaminergic transmission,
but also serotonergic transmission.
- Yeah.
- Which is to my knowledge,
a kind of a rare state
for the brain to be in
that typically it's more
of a seesaw dopaminergic
drive towards external goals
or more serotonergic drive towards
more plasticity or comfort
with what one already has.
And so with both those systems amplified,
the only way I can describe
it subjectively is that it,
everything sort of funneled back in,
and it was almost like a
pursuit of inner landscape.
And I can only imagine what it
would be like in the context
of doing this with somebody
else also taking MDMA.
I have no idea what that's like.
That's my report of the experience.
I know that the experience can vary.
What are your thoughts about the chemistry
and what sorts of states
do you think MDMA is creating
that can explain why it's
a useful therapeutic tool
in some cases and what sorts
of cases those might be.
- Sure, sure.
To clarify, I think part
of what we're starting
with is this is very different
than the psychedelics, right?
Which are seeding our
consciousness in these deep centers
of the brain, right?
Whereas what MDMA is
doing is sort of flooding
with positive neurotransmitters, right?
In certain parts of the brain.
And I think what that creates
is a greater permissiveness
inside to entertain or approach
different things, right?
So I think where we see it's tremend,
my read of the data is around potentially
and we're seeing in some
of the trials, right?
Tremendous benefit for trauma, right?
And you think about what we
were talking about earlier,
how this reflexive, guilt, shame,
hypervigilance, avoidance, right?
And when these systems
are flooded with these neurotransmitters,
it's more permissive to sort
of think about that, right?
And to think about that without again,
all the chatter of that's your fault,
or you're never going to get
anywhere because of that,
or you know what that means, right?
They could kind of go away
and then we can think about it
in a way that isn't through
the lens of fear, right?
And I think that's,
the power there is that
it's permissive of approaching something,
contemplating something,
a different, a novelty as we
talk about a de novo approach.
And I think that's also why the experience
can vary because you could also see how,
if you're not thinking
about something, right?
So there's not a clinical guidance to it,
you could be in a state where like,
hey, I just feel good, right?
And I'm thinking about good things.
And like, that can feel good, right?
But it, but that's not necessarily
problem solving, right?
So the clinical guidance says,
hey, let's take that state and
do something with it, right?
Let's Now that you're in this state,
let's make hay while the
sun is shinning, right?
You're in a state where we can look
at things that are traumatic, right?
We can approach them from
a de novo perspective.
And I think it's part,
I think that explains why
you had these different
experiences from one to the other,
because your brain is just in a state
that's conducive to something, right?
But if there's not
the mechanism to have that thing happen,
like conducive to something therapeutic,
then you might go there on your own.
Or you might just be in a state
where you have a sense of wellbeing
and you sit with that.
- Which sort of seems like a waste to me.
I mean, this is what I tell
people when they ask about MDMA.
I said, at least from my experience
that the potential hazard
there is that in that very high
dopaminergic, serotonergic state,
there were moments where I
felt like I could get excited
about any one specific concept
that I might even just think
about, for instance,
water and how nourishing it is,
and really just go down the path of water
and the world and all
the water and you can,
you're in a state that is
very prone to suggestion.
- [Paul] Yes.
- Internal suggestion.
And so the guidance turned out,
the guidance from the clinician
turned out to be immensely
valuable in allowing me
to go into my own heads
for bits of time, but
then also to resurface
and share and exchange in a way to,
I'm trying really get something out of it
that was useful and that I could export
because of course water is wonderful,
but I'm not really interested in growing
my relationship to water.
- [Paul] Yes.
And I really felt like in,
I could understand for the,
I never went to raves
or anything growing up.
I never did MDMA recreationally,
but I understood for the first time
how people could get really
attached to an environment
and feel connected to things.
Because I think with all that serotonin,
you just feel connected
to everything around you.
So I think it's a slippery slope there.
- Yes.
- And I don't know what the future
of the clinical use of MDMA looks like,
but I would hope that whoever's thinking
about I'm guiding these sessions
is really thinking carefully,
also about evolving the practice
to help people really move through
in a sequential way
so they can leave with something valuable.
- Yes, 100%, 100%.
These are such powerful tools.
And again, if they're powerful tools
and we're using them without
respect for them, right?
Without clinical guidance,
we incur risk, right?
I mean, you know,
getting obsessed with water
while it probably isn't going to
hurt you, right?
But if someone is out using it,
they're around other people,
what one can feel positively about
or become sort of obsessed
in the short term about
can be very counterproductive, right?
It can be a lot of risk to that.
So I think it anchors back to
these are very powerful tools.
We're coming to understand
them much, much more.
And we're coming to understand
that they have immense
potential to be helpful to us.
But I think and hope that
that only also increases
our respect for those
modalities and what can come,
what negative can happen
if we're not respectful.
- It's going to be very interesting
to see where all of this goes
in the next few years, not
just in Oregon, but elsewhere.
One way or another it's happening.
It seems to have a momentum
that is not going to stop.
So very exciting area to be sure.
- I agree.
- I have a question about language.
In your book,
you talk about how we need to be careful
about the use of language around trauma.
- [Paul] Yes.
- Maybe problem solving and
problem describing in general.
At one extreme,
you hear that your
brain and your body hear
every word you say, and, you know,
we have to be so careful with language.
And that actually frightened
me for a number of years,
'cause I would hear that
and I thought, gosh,
if I just think that something is bad
now it's going to hurt me worse,
which itself is part of that whole,
packing down of an issue.
Very hard to avoid thoughts
without distraction.
- [Paul] Yes.
- So that's one extreme,
on the other hand,
I can say, I can tell somebody,
I love them with a tone of hatred.
I can tell somebody I hate
them with a tone of love.
- [Paul] Yes.
- So how should we think about
language in parsing trauma?
And in your book you talk about,
you give some cautionary notes
about talking about depression, trauma
and PTSD in terms that that might diminish
their real severity in some cases.
And I was really struck by that.
So maybe just touch on
how should we talk about these
things in a way that doesn't
diminish them for ourselves
or for other people.
And at the same time honors the fact
that there's a lot of trauma out there.
- [Paul] Right
- And there's a lot of
depression out there
and we need to talk about it.
- Yeah.
I think this a very complicated
and in many ways convoluted topic,
like I think it's wonderful
that we have language,
but boy, language leads
us astray often too.
You think about how we,
how people define words?
Someone says a word, what is it?
Does that person know
what that word means?
What nuance are they taking from? it
We just have to be very
careful what we're saying
and what we're communicating.
And I think this doesn't mean because,
there's a sort of phenomenon now
where people are trying
to control language
I think too much,
like you can't say anything
that someone else might find
hurtful or you have to refer to people
in ways they choose to be referred to,
even if those are ways that
others don't understand,
or ways they themselves have
decided or ways that might be
psychologically or clinically unhelpful.
So I think the over control
of language is not good,
but I think the specificity of language
of what are we trying to
say, how are we defining it?
Or even the word trauma, right?
We're talking about trauma.
So we want to define
what that means, right?
It doesn't just mean like,
oh, anything kind of negative, right?
Because then that dilutes it
down to meaning nothing, right?
It also doesn't just mean,
injury and combat, right?
Like we have to talk about what that is.
So I think anchoring it
to something that rises
to the magnitude of
overwhelming our coping skills
and changing us,
like then at least I define
it that way and I can
communicate that to you
and we can understand
what we're talking about, right?
I think that another aspect
of language, while again,
we need this middle ground and
I don't think that it is okay
for the over control of language
to shut down expression,
but we also have to acknowledge,
how we're so much less
distanced from each other
through social media.
And I think social media can do very,
very good things as hopefully
we're doing now, right?
But it can also be used to harm people
from a distance, right?
And how much hatefulness
is there out there
that I think comes from anger
and frustration in people,
back to trauma, right?
Where people just want to be angry
and it's not really issues
that they're talking about,
but then there's a target of that anger
and people feel beleaguered by that.
And the words that people use sometimes
are so awful that someone reading that,
like if you're in the demographic
that's being targeted, right?
And you're reading that, I mean,
how does a person not feel, not feel,
be set upon vulnerable, right?
And then I think that also fuels,
things like we just had this
terrible shooting in Buffalo, right?
Like just hate motivated, right?
And I think that,
because that kind of language
becomes very real to people
who may take it in,
it fuels their hate and then
they do something to enact it,
which of course creates greater feel
and fear and vulnerability.
And I think there was
some civility and decorum
that was in our world,
not that long ago, right?
I mean, you know, I'm in my early fifties,
I'm not that old, right?
But I remember a time
when in political discourse,
say people were civil
to one another, right?
Now so much, I mean, it's
not all of it, right?
But there's an acceptance of things
that are just bombastic, right?
It's a circus side show sometimes
of people being just angry and aggressive
and it's not really linked to anything,
although it's allegedly
linked to something,
but then other people's
anger can attach to it.
And it's not about what it's about,
but it's about aligning with the anger
and I think that there is so much damage
that comes from that.
And I think, should we have,
should it be okay that
people sometimes are talking,
communicating, using language in ways
that would like get us suspended
from middle school, right?
Ways I don't want my
eight year old to see,
I mean, is that really okay?
Or do we need to take a stand
for like rational use of language?
I don't want my use of
language to be over controlled
by someone who thinks
they sort of understand
better than the rest of us
how to communicate with us.
Okay, I don't want that.
What's stereotypically
a sort of idea of the left say, right?
At least in our society,
but I also don't want,
language, it can be so angry
and so aggressive that it is perpetuating
or spreading vulnerability and
that it facilitates trauma.
And I think we could set
standards as a society
where we say, look, I
don't want anybody in power
who's going to behave that way, right?
I don't care if their
whole agenda is like,
make Paul Conti's life better.
I'm still not going to
vote for you, right?
If you're behaving towards others
in a way that's denigrating,
you're behaving in a way that I feel
essentially ashamed of, right?
And I feel that a lot, right?
I see the politics, you
know, I see things play out.
It's not always political, of
course not always political,
but I see things play out
and I think, oh my gosh,
I feel embarrassed.
Like we we're somehow okay with this.
Well, it doesn't matter which side
of the political spectrum it's coming to.
And I think that's an
indicator that what we're doing
is really hurtful to us.
People become more angry.
They attach to the anger.
People feel more beleaguered.
There's more divisions between us.
And it seems more and more like,
well, we can only really
identify with people
who are just like us
and like, what does that really mean?
I mean, the divisions
that it creates between us
and that promotes so many
negative things, right?
I mean, think about ways
in which it promotes
white supremacy, right?
It's just one example, right?
And we've seen that play out
that this is really bad for us.
And we've got to look at that.
I mean, if we don't look at that,
I don't think something
is going to happen.
Like something is happening, right?
It's happening now.
- Yeah, and I'm, it really, to my mind,
it really seeps down into the soil
of everything that we're talking about.
- Yes.
- On all sides.
- [Paul] Yes.
- People are activated.
People are upset about
one thing or the other.
- Right.
- No one is immune from upset
regardless of political affiliation.
- [Paul] Right.
- Everybody seems to be upset nowadays.
- As I was hearing you talk about this,
I feel a lot of resonance
with what you said
and I also am hoping you run for office.
- Thank you.
I don't think I have the gumption for that
but thank you for.
- [Andrew] Well, that would be wonderful.
- Thank you.
I'd like to talk about a concept
of taking care of one's self.
This comes up in the book.
- [Paul] Yes.
- This is something we talk
a lot about on this podcast.
I mean, I think people have
heard me blab endlessly,
and I'll probably go into the grave
telling people to get sunlight
in their eyes when they can
and to try and get proper
sleep and to have a few tools
for reducing their anxiety in real time
and on and on and on.
- [Paul] Right.
- We hear about this concept
of taking care of oneself
and I think at a surface level,
it can sound a little bit
light, you know, oh, take care,
take care, take good care.
But to me it's a deep
and powerful concept.
- [Paul] Yes.
- And I was very happy
to see it in your book
and also to learn a lot of ideas
about what that really looks like,
because whether or not
somebody is in the early stages
of considering whether
or not they have trauma
or is in the deep stages of working
that through or has made
it through the tunnel
some distance taking care of oneself
is an ongoing process.
- [Paul] Yes.
- I'd love for you to just describe
what taking care of oneself
means to you as a clinician.
And of course the practices and things
that you encourage people to do.
But how should we think about taking care
of oneself because on one extreme,
you could imagine massages
or treats vacations
and chefs for hire that
take care of everything
for ourselves.
And on the other extreme, you could say,
leaning into life in a way
that you're paying attention
to small things while
working very, very hard.
So it's such a big concept,
how do you think about
taking care of one's self?
How should I take care of myself?
- [Paul] Sure.
- How should people
take care of themselves?
- Sure.
- I see here, what I think
is a very fascinating dichotomy, right?
That in some ways, like,
think about how complex
our brains are, right?
How complex our psyches,
our unconscious minds are.
There's so much complexity
there, but on the other hand,
psychological concepts that are consistent
with health are often very simple, right?
Which I don't mean light, right?
But simple, straightforward, right?
And I think self-care is
absolutely one of them.
I mean, how much is talked about,
how to take care of one self
that just skips over the basics
that are necessary as a
building block for all else.
So it doesn't matter how many
chefs or vacations or whatever
a person has if the basics of
self-care aren't squared away.
And it's not a light concept to say like,
are you sleeping enough, right?
Are you eating well?
Are you getting natural light?
Are you interacting with people
who are good to interact with, right?
Are you accepting negative
interactions in your life?
Are you living in circumstances
that make you feel okay or not?
They're very basic premises,
but so often we're not
looking at them at all, right?
We're not looking at them at
all because we tend to skip
over them and we tend to
skip over them either,
because, again, in some automatic way
that sometimes is trauma driven
or we're not going to look at that, right?
And often not taking care of ourselves
can have the punishment
distraction, right?
There's so much that can come into that.
Or our sense of power is,
is tied to not taking care of ourselves.
I mean, I'll give you
an example is I tend to,
for whatever reason do reasonably well
with very poor self care, right?
And like, that was very adaptive
when I was into medical training, right?
And I'm like, okay, I can eat a lot today.
I can not eat, right?
I can sleep two hours.
I can sleep eight, right?
I mean, overall, that's not good.
And it hasn't been good
for me as I've aged.
But then I realized some look,
I'm doing all these things
to make myself healthier,
but like what, I ignored that, right?
And why am I ignoring it?
That was a key question.
Why am I ignoring it?
Because somewhere inside of me, as it was,
and still to some extent is,
this idea that my ability to
be really functional, right?
To generate success in the world around me
is tied to my ability to do that, right?
That, oh, but if I stop
doing that and now I'm like,
I'm eating and sleeping regularly,
then I'm going to lose some edge.
So even I think about this all the time,
but I realize,
hey, I'm also, I'm not
doing it inside, you know?
And I think it's really grounding
to the basics that really help us of like,
what are the basics of what I'm doing
and not doing in my life, diet, exercise,
sleep, people, circumstances,
leisure activities.
I mean, sunlight.
I think immensely important
and dramatically undervalued.
- Well, I want to thank you for that.
And I want to thank you
for today's discussion.
I found it to be incredibly informative
and I know our listeners will also.
I also want to thank
you for the work you do.
I mean, you obviously run an incredibly
robust clinical practice
that I'm aware that you're
constantly trying to improve,
even though it's operating at
the highest levels already.
- I appreciate that.
- I really, the reason
why you're here today
is because I've done
a wide and deep search
for people in these areas.
And there are so few who have
the background in medical
training and physiology,
in the psychoanalytic
and psychiatric realm
and also have a grounding
toward the future,
of what's coming and who can encapsulate
so many different orientations
and bring them together
into a coherent piece.
So I really thank you.
- I so appreciate that.
- Yeah, and for your
book, which is incredible,
I will go on record saying,
I think this is the
definitive book on trauma.
- Wow, thank you.
- And I really encourage people
to read it and will continue
to encourage people to read it.
It has so many valuable takeaways
and insights and tools there.
So on behalf of the listeners and myself,
thank you so much for joining us today.
- You're very welcome.
And I take that to heart
and I'm very appreciative
of being here, so you're very welcome
and thank you as well.
- Thank you.
Thank you for joining me
for my discussion with Dr. Paul Conti.
I also highly recommend that
you explore his new book,
which is "Trauma: The Invisible Epidemic,
How Trauma Works and How
We Can Heal From It."
It's an exceptional resource,
both for those that have trauma
and those that don't have trauma
or those that suspect
they might have trauma.
Again, it's a deep dive
into what trauma is
and offers many simple
tools that anyone can apply
with a therapist or not, in
order to heal from trauma.
And if you'd like to
learn more about Dr. Conti
and the work he does
directly with patients,
please check out his website,
pacificpremieregroup.com.
We've also provided a
link to both the book
and pacificpremieregroup.com
in the show note captions.
If you are learning from and
or enjoying this podcast,
please subscribe to our YouTube channel.
That's a terrific zero
cost way to support us.
In addition, please
subscribe to the podcast
on both Spotify and Apple
and on both Spotify and Apple,
you can also leave us up
to a five star review.
On YouTube, you can leave us comments
or suggestions about
content that you'd like us
to cover as well as suggestions of future
guests that you'd like us
to host on the podcast.
We do read all those comments.
Please also check out
the sponsors mentioned
at the beginning of today's episode.
That is the best way to
support this podcast.
Not so much in today's episode,
but in many previous episodes
of the Huberman Lab Podcast,
we discuss supplements.
While supplements aren't
necessary for everybody,
many people derive
tremendous benefit from them,
for things like improving
the transition time
and the depth of sleep each night,
for improving focus, for managing anxiety
and for many other
aspects of mental health,
physical health and performance.
For that reason,
the Huberman Lab Podcast has partnered
with Momentous supplements
because first off,
they are of the very highest quality.
They also ship internationally,
which many other supplement
companies do not.
And we wanted to have a one
stop location where people could
find and access the
supplements that are discussed
on the Huberman Lab Podcast.
So if you go to
livemomentous.com/huberman,
you'll find many of the
supplements that are commonly
discussed on the Huberman Lab Podcast.
I should just mention that the
catalog of supplements there
will be expanding in the
weeks and months to follow,
but already a number of them for sleep
and focus and other
aspects of mental health,
physical health and performance
are already there at
livemomentous.com/huberman.
If you're not already following
Huberman Lab on Instagram
and Twitter, please do so.
There I cover science
and science based tools,
some of which overlaps with the content
to the Huberman Lab Podcast,
but much of which is distinct
from the information covered
on the Huberman Lab Podcast.
We also have a newsletter
called the Neural Network Newsletter,
where we offer distilled information.
So lists of protocols
and key takeaways from podcast episodes.
If you want to sign up for the newsletter,
all it requires is your email.
Please know that we do not
share your email with anybody.
We have a very clear privacy policy.
You can find all that by
going to hubermanlab.com.
There's a menu there where you can sign up
for the Neural Network Newsletter.
You can also immediately get access
to some example newsletters.
So you know what the
newsletter is all about.
So thank you once again for
joining me for my discussion
with Dr. Paul Conti and last,
but certainly not least,
thank you for your interest in science.
[upbeat rock music]